This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Oh yeah,
no,
both of those rides had no wonder he wanted to give us a ride again.
Yeah.
We had to.
You had this where you have the Uber driver who's terrible,
but you're,
you're respectful.
Like you're just like,
I'm just,
you know,
kind of bite your tongue.
Well,
you want to live.
Yeah.
You want to live.
I complain.
And then you're just like,
I'm not going to be a dick.
And then they're like,
uh,
yeah,
I'll give you my card and you can just hit me up directly.
And you're like,
for what?
For more of that shit.
I'm trying to get nauseous.
Why?
Why would I call you?
And they're like,
this way,
we have our own relationship,
you know,
direct.
And I'm like,
no,
thanks.
Well,
my favorite is that the second guy's car reeked of the Cologne.
Yeah.
Wanting to throw up the whole time.
My favorite also was that this guy goes,
you know,
who was a dick.
Yeah.
Uh,
and he talked about like a,
a famous basketball player and I was like,
Oh really?
That's too bad.
Like I guess it happened.
He was like,
yeah,
it was a real asshole.
And I was like,
yeah,
that sucks.
He's like,
yeah,
I mean,
I went to drop him off and I asked him to take a picture and then he was just
like,
no.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
Yeah,
you made it sound.
This guy was a dick out of nowhere.
You mean you were driving him and your professional job and then you will
insisted on a photo and someone didn't want it to be not in the mood because he
thinks he's just getting a ride to the airport as well.
Everything's,
he can not deal with you at the moment.
My favorite,
like everybody should always want to take pictures with me and said he's a human
being.
Maybe the guy's tired.
Makes him feel like you're fucking taking pictures with you asshole.
Yeah.
Mother fucker.
This is Scorpion,
Scorpion produced by Mike Go.
I appreciate it.
Appreciate you must.
Um,
here's my,
uh,
my two big ads this week.
If you don't know now,
you know,
um,
so my Boston week,
I actually am going back and forth between the Shivaya and the,
the Wilbur,
you know,
normally you play,
do you play one or the other?
Um,
so if you wondered why it's the back and forth,
it's just because the Wilbur wasn't available.
Normally I would just do a Wilbur run,
you know,
like stay there.
So,
um,
Thursday there's two,
right?
No,
sorry.
Friday there's two at the Shivaya there.
The late shows almost sold out now to Saturday at the Wilbur.
We're adding a Sunday,
Jesus Christ and had at the [inaudible].
So it goes,
it goes,
uh,
that's how my agent says,
Hey,
is that wrong?
The French,
it's from the Chevalier Chivalry.
The shovel re is going to go a on presale Wednesday.
The Code Word is Boston.
The word is Boston.
If you want to get tickets,
uh,
noon,
local time code word is Boston.
That's in Medford.
Um,
thank you so much.
Boston area has been extremely generous and kind to me.
I suggest for Boston.
Yeah,
sure.
Balls.
10.
Ballston.
Yeah.
That sounds like a really good idea.
Um,
yeah.
No,
it's better than what you got going.
It's not even how you say that city's name is balls town.
Okay.
Um,
the other,
the other big one I'm excited about is we,
uh,
we added a show in Nashville at the Ryman April 14th at 9:30 PM.
And what did we just talk about?
Oh,
and Louisville.
Louisville.
Uh,
at the Browne theater,
which I know would make you happy.
Yeah.
The ad requests that Tuesday,
May 28th.
It's a,
it's going on sale.
A local,
I think 10:00 AM local time.
Wednesday this Wednesday.
So thank you.
Tuesday,
May 28th I'll be in Louisville,
Kentucky.
The Brown theater.
Yeah.
Uh,
that's a,
that's that,
but then the rest of the day,
right?
They're all there.
Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
It starts off January 4th to take it down to her in man,
friend disco.
I will be up there.
Um,
and I'm bringing the Great Josh Potter with me at the Masonic.
So you think you'll talk about murder?
We might,
I dunno
about Eugene.
January 10th here in Hollywood,
California at the comedy store.
I'm headlining the Maine or,
and get your tickets for that.
January 31st February through February 2nd Denver,
Colorado at the comedy works now.
Um,
yeah.
In town.
That's coming downtown.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Come on.
One February 23rd west Salem Springs.
I've rebooked that one in Oklahoma at the Cherokee Casino February 28th through
March 2nd Madison,
Wisconsin at the comedy club on state April four through six mini apple tits and
a soda.
Finally,
I'm going there.
I've never been.
Yeah,
we're doing ag and he,
acme,
not the accurate acme.
Now I've been told there's some sporting event happening that week,
so if you guys are traveling from out of town,
I would recommend getting your hotels now because there's some major sporting
thing going down that way,
which we can,
is it April four through six?
Oh,
my agent jeans was telling me about it.
I have to book my hotel right now.
Oh,
go ahead.
May 10th and 11th Tempe,
Arizona,
Tevye,
and then June 20th through 22nd Washington deck come at the DC Improv.
All ticket links at Christina P on line.
Get sure genes.
There you go.
I like to give a special shout out to all the mommies who came out to fill her
dot delphia and to Dork titties.
Ah,
what a phenomenal ride I had.
I can't thank you guys.
Amazing.
It was some something special.
Really special.
Proud of her gene.
Very,
very excited for you.
Uh,
no.
Really big things are happening.
Pink jeans are happening.
Big Jeans are happening for you.
Big episode.
You're ready to get started,
gene.
Sorry.
All right,
let's start this.
It's hard to
fold tramadol.
That's another
big Oh,
gay person.
No,
I didn't mean that.
I've seen
and a lot of people messaging the talking trash about this water.
Why?
I Dunno.
Maybe it's a,
well,
it's purified.
So I think that's another thing that Martin taught us is not,
I don't actually drink the bottle.
The water that comes in that bottle,
I refill it.
I don't like to waste the plastic and truth be told.
I know I bought reusable containers for water.
They taste like plastic.
Let's look at the marketing behind this.
What makes us essential better.
Our proprietary process turns water from any source into supercharged ionized
alkaline water.
It's even too pure to be tasted,
to be tested by Ph strips.
Ah,
let's see.
That's your tap water.
I'm drinking.
That's filtered water and he's like my house.
Yup,
you got it.
You got to love a guy who's angry enough to make a post.
Yes,
use a naughty word,
but is self aware enough to correct himself right in that moment,
he was so angry.
He was like,
all right,
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it like that.
I think you'd ever hear that.
I didn't mean that
you let it go.
He was like real talk.
I think in New York I may have done that.
Wow.
Ah,
Geez.
I can't say that anymore.
You can't say I do the same thing as this guy sometimes.
I didn't mean that.
You know why he looks at his upset here and I'll let him him explained.
This is why he's so upset.
There's another gay person messages me a picture of your ass and your ass looks
like a woman's ass and I think it's a woman.
And I open it.
Yeah.
And I get aroused
ever fucking game.
I'm going to kill that mother fucker.
So apparently he's mad that he's becoming sexually aroused by men's booties that
he thinks are women's booties.
Has that ever happened to you?
Be Honest.
Like where you're on,
you're surfing the web looking for stuff to be true.
Me Too.
And you're like,
this chick's hot and then you're like,
whoa,
that's not a chick.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And then do you beat yourself?
Cause it sounds like he's really beating himself up.
He's getting himself like,
or even just having the moment,
right?
Like that's what he's right.
I mean I don't know who that hasn't happened too.
You've seen like,
you know,
you can see I've even seen like a,
a girl in public,
like she's pretty and they'd be like,
oh that's a guy like Matt and non binary.
Yeah.
You'll just see like long hair and they'd be a profile and you were like,
what's an attractive woman at a guy like that that happens for sure.
But yeah,
on,
if you're like looking on porn sites,
you can definitely get tricked,
Ya know?
I mean obviously they're going to advertise that,
but you can scroll,
you know they have like the popups and all the,
well I have clicked on and people have sent me,
you've seen the thing right where it's like someone will send you a video and
you open it and it pants down and be like gorgeous face,
gorgeous body you'll see takes no shit.
And then they pan,
you know,
like all the way down and then like huge Dick and yeah.
Okay.
That's what I was just going to say is that I've accidentally clicked on
thumbnails I thought were one direction and then you're like,
oh,
those are,
those are two dudes.
He makes it sound.
Let me look how angry he is here.
He makes it sound like people,
well he's saying that are sending him,
so he's like,
you're forcing me to calm.
Well,
but I mean he's gay dudes.
But suddenly he said they're sending right?
Doesn't he say they're sending,
which means that he's,
is he being like targeted
messages?
Messages.
So someone's messaging him that means directly being like,
you should look at this.
Interesting.
Do you get sent those a lot?
No.
I know I only get,
I get,
um,
the complements,
mostly from men.
You get the bear communities,
the gay bear community is definitely your demo.
No,
the way that I do it,
that is kind of,
they'll be like,
um,
oh my God,
you're so funny.
I love,
you know,
the special or the podcast and I'm like,
oh cool.
And there'll be like the,
you're also pretty cute.
And I'm like,
all right.
Does it doesn't hurt that you're easy on the yeah,
I've gotten that.
I'll just wanted to set,
you're hilarious.
And also the hottest come on.
And I'm like,
God.
Okay.
And do you think there,
how would that upset?
It doesn't upset me,
but I like,
I liked their tactic because it's like I'm gonna throw it in there.
I'm going to just throw the hook out.
That's what guys do ever know.
If he's going to be like,
wow.
Wow,
your Q two,
that's men straight or gay.
Yes.
A matter guys.
Just go see what happens.
Go fishing.
These are the guys that fish on the Santa Monica pier.
Like,
you know,
you're not going to catch good fish,
but you're still gonna.
I'm going to throw the lines.
Yeah,
I know the straight version of that guy.
Well,
you know,
I'm a guy and that's true.
And then high school and college and you always have that friend even into your
20s I would say.
Who's like,
he just compliments every woman and you're like,
Jesus,
this incessant complementing.
Yeah,
but he does it because every once in a while get something going,
I love you girl.
You're more beautiful.
And I remember one of my stars in the sky,
he would be,
he would say what he would say this to girls were in public.
I was always the fucking reckless,
just staring down,
you know,
it's not antisocial.
Yeah.
And he would go,
he would go,
uh,
how you doing?
Or she be like,
oh,
I'm good.
How are you?
He's like,
I'm better now that I'm talking to you.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
He's like,
now the whole nights making sense and shit like that.
Right.
How many of those girls were like,
oh my God,
you're so sweet.
He looks up with a number of them course.
Yeah,
but it would be a certain type of girl if you know what I mean.
Broken.
Well just one who's like,
I'm down to fuck over some compliments.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm guessing that's interesting cause what I would say no we don't like that
because what I liked though,
here's what I do like about him.
He had success and it was no where there's this nagging bullshit of like make
sure you take her down to get her.
That's a tactic.
I don't even feel comfortable around that tactic when I was like,
when I hear guys do that,
I know it works.
It works to the insecure girl.
I was amused by my friend who would do,
he would always do the positive spin.
He would make like a seven feel like a 10 you know,
and look at work and a few times a guy tried it.
That nagging stuff on me,
I'm like get the fuck out.
He may be physically uncomfortable even as somebody not involved in doing it.
Guy Was said that to me.
I literally,
I forget even what he said,
like,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't remember how,
but I remember being approached that way and just be like,
ah,
yeah.
Well that's what not what they want the girl to go like,
Oh yeah,
wait,
I should wear my hair up.
Oh,
and I do like the positive approach.
I'd rather have a guy of course better.
It's better now that you're here,
girl.
Yeah.
He was ridiculous.
So ridiculous.
Of course.
You know I'm talking about had a pretty good batting average.
He just,
because he's sweet,
he's attractive.
He's,
he means no harm.
That's why that works.
I'm working people.
He was just like,
girl,
my whole,
my whole life's changing right now.
Yeah.
For real though.
Like a boy band,
Huh?
God,
you'll deserve to be in a place like you deserve a better place.
I've got to get you kind of Joe's tactic of him being,
like you said,
you got to leave with your ex boyfriend.
Exactly.
Don't do that.
Don't,
don't look back.
Don't look back.
Well,
I'll tell you one thing about this guy to this guy right here.
I don't think,
I don't think he knows the Oscars.
Hey,
can you believe that shit?
Can you fucking even believers know how,
how nonsense has all this?
How much,
how much further is this going to go before somebody sounds,
they hysteria keeps growing.
It is hysteria at a new law.
If you don't know,
um,
I'd be surprised.
But Kevin Hart was tapped to host the Oscars.
Then they uh,
pulled up some eight and nine and maybe even 10 year old tweets.
Yeah.
Um,
and they were like,
these are homophobic,
anti gay.
And it was things like,
oh here's,
let me give you,
the one of them is,
uh,
if I came home and found out my son was gay,
I'd break a doll house over his head,
no areas.
And then they're like,
you're going to attack your son.
So I dunno what makes me the craziest about all this stuff.
I mean,
a lot of it does is when people pretend cause they're pretending,
they pretend like they don't get what part of these statements are jokes.
That's what makes me the craziest.
Like,
or what part of it when they pretend to misinterpret it,
you know what they did it with norm Macdonald's when he did the uh,
his interview where he was like,
yeah,
so I hooked up Roseanne with Louie cause they're the only two people that have
been through something like that.
And they're like,
what do you mean been through something like that?
There's victims here and it's like,
yeah,
but not the media.
Understand what he was saying.
You don't need an explanation and you're purposely out pro purposely pretending
to be outraged because that's a thing to do now and you have your target but you
know exactly what he meant.
You know that he meant the year or two people that lost everything in a day and
probably only know what that feels like.
I've gathered not irrespective of the other obviously.
And then with Kevin's thing,
it's like,
so he,
him threatening to break a doll house over his young sons surfaces is uh,
because he found that his gay,
like it might be fun,
not be funny,
it might be Hacky,
it might be like tasteless.
But or whatever,
but you're going to act like,
hey,
he's probably going to really hurt his son like that.
That's so exhausting that I have to,
because I know that even if you are outraged that you know that that's a joke.
So now we're doing this Improv in public together where I'm going to acknowledge
that I,
I understand your outrage now I understand what you mean because he really
shouldn't hurt his son for saying that he was going to be gay or has apologized
already and that was his point.
And secondly,
he's already addressed it.
It's the corporations who acknowledge these.
First of all,
if you talk to the average person on the street,
I don't see anybody outraged.
I don't think most people give a shit.
It's these weird marginal groups,
I guess on the Internet that are coming after these corporations.
And then the corporations kowtow to this lunacy.
So if the,
whoever's hiring Kevin just goes,
oh really?
You're upset too bad Kevin Hart's our guy.
Yeah.
Instead of like exactly appeasing these Donnie's.
That's why it's ridiculous.
You really got to celebrate Kevin for nothing,
of course.
And also you know what's happening too I think is a lack of context.
Like what you're saying is that people are taking things out of context.
It's kind of the way we read tweets.
You only read a hundred and whatever characters and completely out of context of
space and time.
It's like,
it's like a comedian's doing,
you know,
anti wife jokes or whatever the fuck in the fifties you're going to hold all
those guys responsible or,
yeah.
It's just silly.
I mean exactly like 10 years is a big difference and it really,
it is in this era for sure.
It is for sure.
It is.
I mean,
when,
when he made that tweet,
like,
you know,
again,
it could be tasteless and not,
not funny or kind of offensive,
but like it's a different time.
It's before we had legalized gay marriage.
So his tweet,
okay,
here's the Yo,
if my son comes home and tries to play with my daughter's doll house,
I'm going to break it over and set his head and saying,
my voice stop.
That's gay.
Hmm,
okay.
Uh,
then he,
he was,
he caught,
his son is then three old son having a gay moment.
He was not proud of,
you should nip it in the bud.
He said,
and then in a 2011 routine,
I remember they're just waiting.
They're just waiting for you to get certain opportunities.
Yes.
And then here's the thing,
you need somebody in Kevin Hart's position who literally doesn't need it.
Like there's some times when you're tapped to host something like that where
you're like,
this kind of put me out front again.
Like it doesn't need,
it doesn't need it for the attention.
Right.
Doesn't need it for the promotion,
doesn't need it for the money.
Like they're lucky to have him,
you know,
um,
for you to be in that position and be like,
I'm not going to do the apology thing.
It's huge.
We need more comedians to be like,
I'm not fucking apologizing.
Fire me.
Go get hand.
Right.
Godspeed of,
do whatever the fuck you wanted me to do.
Not doing it right.
He said,
you know,
it's come up before,
which it has he,
he did,
he addressed it in,
in a,
I think it was a rolling stone interview a few years ago.
It's
so stupid.
Well,
um,
we need to stop apologizing as comedians and also,
I'm not sure the apology gets you anything anymore because you apologize and
then you're probably still going to get fired anyways.
Yeah.
So now apologizing.
It serves no purpose.
I think we should do it with Donald Trump is great at doing,
which he never apologizes and that's actually a really smart move.
He doesn't,
he's like a fuck you.
Well,
look at him.
He gets away with murder in the media.
I'm saying,
cause he's like,
no,
fuck you.
This is what I'm doing.
And in a way I respect that because it's like,
okay,
that's the tactic.
Don't apologize because you,
why are we rewarding these marginal a idiots who aren't,
who aren't understanding things contextually.
It's just silly.
It's this is absurdity.
What's happening.
It's totally,
it's a fucking stupid witch hunt.
It's a social justice warrior,
which hunt.
I'm just happy.
The dumbest thing in the fucking world.
He did like after he,
um,
step down,
he sent out an Nepal.
Like you're like,
hey,
if I ever heard anyone I never meant to cause he did it on his terms after
giving up the Gig,
he was like,
I'm not going to do it on your terms.
Um,
but rest assured there's no comedian.
I've never met a comedian in the history of comedians whose intent is to hurt
people's feelings.
That's never the fucking intent.
No,
I know.
That's not what anybody picks up a microphone and sacrifices everything in your
life for a decade just to get paid a nominal amount of money to tell jokes if
people to hurt them.
That's not why we do this.
Right.
Tom,
did you travel across the country and go into severe debt for a decade?
Miss Birthdays,
holidays,
New Year's,
everything to make people pissed off.
That's why you did comedy,
right?
To offend gay people to,
God forbid,
it's just the stupidest fucking thing in the world.
I don't know why they're coming after comics.
It bothers me.
I know it,
but I also like the gravity that people attached to the jokes too.
Like when people are like,
you know what's fucking dumb dummies,
we'll get back on track.
He just,
we just need,
you know,
you gotta you gotta be like,
I screwed up there.
I don't think you do.
Here's what we're going to put on the death list.
Remember we had the,
the,
the person,
uh,
we're going to execute the who listened to videos loudly or make calls loudly.
Yeah,
it's in my act.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well I have a list of he bomb.
I want to kill and it's going to go,
this isn't going to be the next people who don't understand.
Yeah.
Fucking jokes.
Are you kidding me?
It's,
it's,
it's embarrassing.
It really is embarrassing.
It's embarrassing that,
that the culture has evolved at that point.
You know,
that,
um,
that everyone,
cause you know what it is also that that's really annoying is that it's
selective outrage.
So if you're going to attack having heart per pass tweets and things said,
it's not fair that it's just about gay stuff.
You got to get it.
You got to get it all.
Otherwise you're,
you're not being fair.
You're being biased.
I mean,
has it,
he probably,
I don't know,
made fun of a people,
I don't know
different ways.
And we all have,
it's all on the cattle.
But why me?
Why is this the only thing to be outraged by it?
I don't know.
Gotta be outraged by all of it.
There's so many great comedians that have made fun of all these things.
It's all these things that really is,
podcasting is the most amazing thing because you have no boss.
Nobody can tell you anything
in our audience.
Our audience gets it.
I mean,
it's clearly because we talk about the stuff.
We make fun of everything.
And I know I just really want to Kevin Hart
for doing that.
He's like,
I'm not playing the game.
No,
that's stupid.
I'm not playing the game for him.
Yeah.
Um,
and so yeah,
last night we did something we've never done.
Yeah.
We went to the Lakers,
Lakers,
Lowe's lagers,
Omi.
We set it up with our,
uh,
was actually,
we were treated by our agent,
Asian genes and agent jeans
came,
uh,
took us to the game and we saw a great game.
We saw Lebron Dwayne Wade play in the last time.
They'll face each other or at least the last time Dwayne Wade would play at
staples.
He's retiring at the end of the season and you know,
seeing a legendary player and person and here's the thing that I was thrilled
by.
My wife fucking always rolls her eyes at sports,
hates most of the sports and she was like,
we got to go to a Laker game.
You had a good time.
I love it.
I like basketball.
I grew up playing basketball here and there.
I grew up playing basketball.
I mean like I was tall as a girl and so I actually was decent at playing
basketball.
I didn't play it.
I couldn't believe it.
You're like,
that's a traveling call.
I was like,
fuck.
Where have you been?
The one thing I know I like going to go to basketball game again.
Yeah.
I like tennis too.
We can get tennis tickets.
I don't know to fuck Dan is decades or years.
You know what I love most about the Laker game though?
Yeah,
it's the audience.
Yeah.
When they put the camera on,
like the dude who it just made his fucking year to be up on the jumbo tron and
he's like,
oh,
it's really almost look at TV.
Like it's the best moment.
Lose their shit.
They go nuts dude.
They just love it.
Well we
saw it.
I mean that was,
it was down to the wire that game and we saw amazing.
I mean everything from just beautiful basketball,
you know,
like something just really coming together.
Pass Pass Pat.
We saw amazing passes.
We saw kind of blooper plays.
We saw alley,
oops.
You saw guys driving and the whole beautiful threes and it was back and forth,
back and forth.
It was,
it was like a high drama sound like an announcer with all the,
well,
I mean we just got to see so many cool aspects of the game.
It was actually a really good guy.
I,
yeah,
and I never seen a game live.
Like I've never been to staples center.
Actually.
I'm embarrassed to say.
Well,
this is an interesting thing because somebody wrote in,
oddly enough,
an email about something that I wanted to bring to your attention.
Okay.
Somebody wrote in,
I have a question for the mommies.
I says,
actually,
hey Theodore and Caroline,
I have a question for the Mommy and Caroline and dad's really morphed and now
I'm watching the Florida state basketball game right now with my man and I see
how demonically tall number 21 [inaudible].
I tell him,
I bet he can't do a lot of things like riding a car,
take a group picture,
fit in the shower,
get on a plane,
et cetera.
The first thing he says,
meaning her man did to her is I bet his dick is huge.
Yeah.
I told him he is gay and to go jack his friends four strokes
and he said that is every man's first thought when they see a really tall guy.
Is this Ma,
is this true?
Are All men a little gay inside love to all my mother's keeping it high and
tight from Kansas.
Lauren,
well Lauren,
I got to tell you something.
Your man is 100% correct.
First thing I think about when I meet most guys is I wonder how big his dick is.
No,
but definitely a huge guy.
Well,
when I see a bunch of big dudes running back and forth on the court,
that is first when I think of,
and then I compare their Dick Sizes in my head.
Yeah.
And I think Lebron's got the biggest dick just because he's the king of bad
energy.
Oh,
he's got a lot of big to counter just,
but I dunno.
I mean it's Kinda hard to,
here's the guy that she was talking about.
Okay.
This guy right here and he's got a huge one.
He's seven four.
That's crazy.
Seven these guys,
I mean,
yeah,
these guys are big.
Look at this.
I mean,
yeah.
I mean if you look at his leg is probably as Dick's probably right around here.
Do you think his balls are big in proportion to his penis or it's just a long
deck and the normal size balls to the balls get bigger too?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think the ball proportion,
I don't think it would be like a 10 inch dick and then little tiny balls.
No,
I think it's probably proportionate.
Yeah.
Do you want to know something crazy gene?
But I had a dream last night that you and I were doing it,
but that you had a big black dog.
Isn't that crazy?
Like you were you,
you were Tom colored
and then your,
but you're dong was like a big black one and I swear it's because I was watching
the Lakers and I was like,
there's not one white guy on this team.
Right?
There's like there's no Larry Bird and you're just like plastic black dick plans
all the time.
I was like,
what do you think most of it was?
Must have been an uncommon,
no,
it was an unconscious the table.
Now tell me
where are you?
No,
I've never dated a black guy.
I never really knew.
Why were you sitting there?
They can't
pass the ball,
pass it.
But I was thinking,
you know,
and I was thinking because they run fast.
You were thinking,
what's going on here?
I didn't know him.
Those loose shorts,
they're dongs flop.
Well No,
they weren't tight compressions underneath.
Oh they do?
Of course.
Otherwise it would be just be a dick and ball fast.
That's what I was thinking about is how do they run with their Dicks,
wet and tight compression shorts.
They're dicks are real issue sprinters.
Sure.
Yeah.
Big Old Dixon balls and they have to tuck them away sometimes.
Sometimes you see them flopping and sprinting.
That's what I'm saying.
You see,
cause I've seen guys playing basketball like in high school,
those swing and they flop and you seen them.
But in the pros they're dicks are too big and their balls up too floppy and they
wear compression shorts.
Yeah.
Otherwise it just be dicks everywhere.
What they're digging balls smell like after a game it probably smell stinky.
Yeah.
Especially for telling me that.
You're just figuring yourself this stuff at night.
Huh?
Were you just like trying to go to bed?
Come on,
show me the compression pants.
Are they porous or are they sweaty?
So it's probably not good for your junk.
Yeah,
the,
yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's not that breathable.
I'm sure your dick and balls probably smell really bad after it.
It's a really interesting details to bring up your Dick and balls.
Probably do smell really bad after a game.
Maybe we can get some confirmation.
Anybody play on the NBA?
Any of any NBA players out there when it confirm what your dick and balls smell
like after a game.
I like to know now.
I grew up in the era of [inaudible] and Kobe and I never,
unfortunately I never got to see them live play.
I did watch the Games on television.
I saw Jill Dan Place live three times.
No,
Michael Jordan.
I saw this on the bowls.
Wasn't he on the,
he was on the car goals.
He was,
I got to see Shequila play.
Um,
that goes massive.
I got to see him play early in his career when he played for Orlando.
I went to games there.
Orlando check.
He'll probably has a huge dick and well,
there's been stories.
It's interesting that you bring that up.
It's,
it's interesting that you bring that up because what happened was there were
many stories about the fact that chuck,
we lay check Quila this enormous man
seven one,
you know,
at some shit now he's probably three 50 but you know,
he played in his prime at u seven one just over 300 and just gigantic giant
human being.
And there was like some,
some hoes,
you know,
something like video hose and stuff that were like his dick ain't all that,
that his dick was not proportionate to what you were seeing.
Again,
what might be happening is that this guy is so big,
right,
that you're expecting a fucking tree fall out and it might be actually big
compared to any average size guy.
Right.
But not big compared to what you're looking at.
Meaning meaning horse,
there's not proportionate.
So maybe he has an eight inch Dick,
which is definitely above average,
but you're like,
I thought this thing was going to be 16 you know?
Yeah.
That's what I would expect from Shakeel.
What'd you tell him that if you met him,
wouldn't you want to see it if you met him?
Yes,
I,
yes,
absolutely.
And I want who was,
I didn't know yet.
So many Black Hawk fantasy.
Oh please.
Who is,
it was a magical Johnson there last night.
No,
no.
The other girl,
he was there.
What's his name?
The old,
they're the old Kareem.
Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
He was there.
Yeah,
he's a shit now.
I grew up watching him as a kid cause he,
they,
they used to wear the short shorts back.
I picture his Dick Polite,
kind of uh,
Kareem's.
Yeah,
no,
it's an,
it's an assaulter.
You think that's a big hog.
I bet you creams.
You got the biggest dick of,
of all of them really?
Just because he's long and lean.
Well,
they're all long and lean not Shaquille.
Shaquille is meat and cheese tall and he's meat and cheese.
It's built like a football player in most basketball players or lean long and
lean.
Yeah.
Like the Harlem Globe trotters.
They all have long lean ones.
How do you know this?
I don't know.
My mom dated them.
I swear to God all of them now know she,
she had,
if she dated a few of them,
what?
Yeah,
my mother,
I see you.
I promise you.
When she came to the country,
she was cute,
blonde,
big tits,
and she worked over at universal.
I swear to God,
and one day I was going through her belongings and she had all these signs.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm trying to tell you a fucking story to the story saying that's my mom
with the globe trotters.
She had all these signs.
It would be easy.
All these signs,
pictures of the globe.
Globe trotters.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and they're all like to eat if you know you're the best,
Dah,
Dah.
And I was like,
how the fuck did you get all these pictures of these globe trotter?
So ranches that I knew them,
I was friends with them.
I went out on a couple of days.
I was like,
yeah,
couple of Ding Dong dates.
Yeah,
I got it.
Thank you.
So nasty.
Okie dokie.
No Dude,
dude,
dude.
Oh,
number curly.
Curly was a short one.
Yeah.
Now did they still have the Harlem Globe trotters?
Yeah,
they still do that today.
that'd be fine.
We should see them next.
Yeah.
Anyways,
this is my new favorite thing are going to Laker games.
I'm a huge new,
genuine,
cool.
I got my glasses of white wine.
I got two glasses of Chardonnay last night.
I had a pretzel.
Yeah,
so it was a lot of fun.
There was a lot of fun.
There was a fucking ass hole next to us who was loudly rooting for the other
team and it fucking so disrespectful.
He was like really rooting for them and I was like,
motherfucker,
you're an la bitch.
Sit down.
He was wearing like a fucking suit,
like a Douche bag.
Get outta here man.
You know it's funny.
Last week my,
one of my favorite moments when we had done again on was when you and I just
looked at each other when he said,
I know what you're going to say.
It was like a,
Oh,
and hold on,
let me get this right.
I know what he did.
I know.
I know what he did it Christine,
right.
I know what the fuck is.
Okay.
Christine,
can I tell you?
I just said,
it's okay.
Christine.
Christine and I been getting emails and people,
people who've known me for a year,
and you're like,
hey,
Christine.
I'm like,
what is happening?
It's going on.
I know.
And then,
uh,
absolute lowest.
You would,
they real.
I'm saying what's really be realistic.
Yeah.
Christian doesn't find out about it or,
sorry,
Christina.
Yeah.
So he,
he did go get it right.
He corrected.
Yeah.
Do you think he remembered or he heard me say it.
Maybe.
Maybe I said like Christina and he was like,
oh,
got to ask him.
But he definitely had a Christine,
Christine,
Christine [inaudible]. [inaudible] [inaudible].
Yup.
Uh,
one of my favorite things,
I usually don't bring this stuff up.
Uh,
two people that can do it because I think you've told it to mean you're like,
everyone really hurt them.
Well,
when people are like,
dude,
you look just like my friend or brother or dad or husband,
and you're like,
look at the photo.
And you're like,
no,
I don't.
No,
You,
uh,
you just show me a guy with a beard.
And they're like,
no,
no.
You guys are twins and so,
but now when it's a friend who does that,
you can be like,
oh,
I can call him out.
So Brendan Schaub hosted this last week.
Hey,
fun fact.
Did you know my barber is Thomson [inaudible] Mexican brother and then here's
the guy
just like him.
No.
Well,
I put fun fact.
Did you know that Brendan Shab has experienced severe head trauma and doesn't
know what his friends look like because I felt like he was the first person that
I could really lay into for this thing.
Brendon,
it's not just a guy with a beard.
That's always what it is.
I would say one out of a hundred of these that I get,
is it somebody that I remotely look like?
I mean,
this guy's got a beard and eyebrows is that he has are twins.
Oh,
you mean like,
Oh yeah,
I see it.
We have a nose.
Like what are you talking about?
This is not you at all here.
Here's some other guys that I looked just like,
there you go.
Well,
that guy's beard.
Okay.
His short hair.
He's got short hair,
but that's really it.
He looks like James Gandolfini this guy more.
Um,
how about this guy?
What are you talking about?
Look at it.
We both have lips,
right?
And then we have different eye colors,
but we are our head is that this round at the top and his beard is that a lot
fuller than yours would say?
There's another guy he taught me.
It's twin.
That's my twin.
He's like 60.
That guy,
uh,
you don't know.
You're talking about there is,
it looks just like me who have beards.
It got left here.
I got left here.
Look,
you see it now.
He's got shoulders.
You've got shovel.
Got Shoulders.
Oh,
there I am.
Now that guy guy's a famous actor and he looks just like me.
Yes.
Yes he does.
Here's another guy.
Look at him.
You realize how many people to send me.
They send me their like,
I'm going to freak you out right now.
You're about to lose your mind.
I just realized
and it's either like either saw your doppelganger or they'll be like my husband
or my dad or my is your twin.
And as basically EAD resell ba like they're like see like see looks just like
you.
And I'm like,
no,
like his black on black on black ensemble.
Yeah.
You're talking about like suit.
It was great,
but I'm talking about that people don't seem,
I get it.
But you know what?
I didn't want to be selfish.
So I also wanted to point out some people that you look just like,
oh yeah,
I like that one.
Yeah.
That's not not,
I do not look like Angelina.
Yeah,
that girl just looked like me.
I could see that.
Except I don't have brown eyes.
Christie Christie.
Yeah.
Have someone sent this in?
It's like this looks like Christina pull had them pull some girl could be me
blonde.
I mean,
but that's,
you think your twins now.
Now I look way more eastern Europe.
Now you on the left that is on the laughed.
Sure does.
It is just blind.
Yeah.
It doesn't look a thing like me.
I think you're starting to get it.
Yeah.
Uh,
at girls a slutty blind.
See,
I'm a different kind of blonde.
I have low lights in my hair and then there's girls who only have the blonde.
Well those are,
those don't look the same.
She's holding a child and you're obsessed with the black hawks of the MBA.
There you are.
There.
I am.
What size are those?
Milkers you think?
Jeez.
Pretty good.
Those are bad.
Big Ones.
Yum.
I wouldn't mind taking.
Okay.
So do you dream about big black boobs?
Um,
I've,
I've dropped about all types of,
of sized tits and asses and everything I had.
My ass is terrible.
It's disgusting.
Jesus.
It's always been disgusting.
Now there's,
um,
there's things really developing in this sector to Juliette.
Oh Man.
You're telling me,
oh my goodness.
So it's grown and grown and we're so thrilled about that.
Lots of photo shops,
art work obviously exploded at the shirts were a hit you guys,
uh,
as we're asking for when we put them out,
they were such a hit that I have socks coming next week.
Um,
those are good morning Julia socks.
And I did a small and larger ones because I know that women would want some,
but it's been,
it's,
it's the hit of the century,
Julia.
I mean,
look,
we never know.
You never really know what resonates with the autonomy.
So happy when it's shit like that.
There's something so pure about this whole thing with Julia and Joe.
We got to meet Julia.
I know.
I've been texting.
I think so.
Let's first of all,
she's crinkled throttle.
She's let's go full throttle with this.
Um,
Jess,
she's awesome at all.
You're not saying it right.
Uh,
so
there's been more people are sending in their unique,
uh,
good morning Julia.
So let me play you some of these.
I love these more than life.
That's a kid.
It's a kid.
Um,
here's another lady,
Julia.
Anyway,
yesterday it was the best day of my life.
You see this?
See that?
Not shock the show.
Hey,
put your backyard.
Don't go back that X.
I'm a fucking kill him to
come on and I love you.
Good morning.
Good Morning Julia.
I just want to say we'll be having a great day.
Sorry about debt.
That's why I say when I'm pouring up for about three or four hours today,
really going for Toronto,
thinking about Joe.
So open up your heart and hope to hear from y'all
always against me.
Hey,
tripped over a fan there.
Hit the floor,
he goes,
there's different parts of Good Morning Julia that I fixate on every now and
then.
But I,
what I've been hearing in my head lately is open up your heart and your arms to
me that you start having that loop.
Different loops we'll play.
Yeah,
I get that too.
What are you living?
Um,
open up your heart and your arms to me heart and arms is a big one.
We'll put up your heart because it's also like open your heart and then he's
like,
and the choice of words.
Yeah,
it's very odd.
You know,
put up your heart.
Cause I thought first I thought it was open up your heart and your arms.
Oh and then I'm like oh no,
he's saying and your arms,
your arms.
And it's also like he was saying like be sweet,
but he's like also be physical because that's really what put up your heart is
an emotional thing.
But also,
yeah,
he meant to say open up your heart and your legs or whatever's in between your
legs.
I'll open that up for you.
Right,
because on the surf,
I love this analysis.
You're right on the surface,
this charming just open up your heart.
But then he layers in the hyper sexual,
it was his brand.
He didn't even,
he wasn't even able to stop his brain doing that cause that's every man.
Even like when a man is like,
let me get the door for you.
You know,
he's thinking,
let me open your legs for you.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You guys are horrible people.
Men are horrible.
Just wired for this.
You guys are terrible.
Terrible.
That is true.
Was there ever a time when you're just a normal,
not sexual.
They go on your way out.
When you're dying,
that's when they get even perverted again.
George Bush was slapping David Copperfield.
Anyway,
open up your hot and you're on more on Julia meet.
Meet you last night of my,
my big ass stadium pool.
Often you get physical with my music on the best days of my life.
And uh,
now you said you wanted to get back together with Gx,
but uh,
me and miss Yearwood would love to go full throttle with you down here.
A studio g I wrote all my own songs from Rodeo to have a kind of thunder roll
all the way down to friends in low places.
All right.
Jt Song you want to yeah,
just uh,
coming to as many shows as you can.
No,
you're my flower.
Flower
kisses.
No trace.
Okay.
What's really neat about this guy is that he meshes two of our favorite things
together.
Garth and Joe.
Two greatest guys of all time.
Joe Brooks.
Yeah.
What a nightmare.
Julie.
Yeah.
No,
you like a strong man.
Not like your ex boyfriend.
I just wanted to show you the ceiling fan and,
and show to you how strong this ceiling fan is.
Demonstrate.
Oh Shit.
So we can,
when you will not go full throttle,
Juliet,
I think you would really take things serious.
Oh my God,
I love this for you.
There's nothing wrong.
Ciao baby.
Huh?
That was scary.
I don't want people hurting themselves because he headed to that fan.
He's,
he's experienced with that fan.
He knows the fans that he knows that the capabilities he does.
He's done that for fun.
Yeah.
Okay.
Morning Julia.
It's so hard to watch.
It's not cool that you called the cops on me.
I keep running the keep finding me.
I had this field here that,
uh,
Bill for you is going to be where our house was going to go.
Now I might have to,
you know,
bury you in it,
but uh,
I got to go more.
Wah Wah.
Ah,
school is a
full travel.
Ciao.
Oh,
it's cute.
It's come full travel.
Yeah.
Julia,
don't believe me.
We found you Julia.
We can't do this here.
Julia.
Julia,
I felt I got to gloss.
Greatest hits.
Julia,
Julia.
No Chow
man.
I love the washout chasing him,
chasing the vehicle too.
I know.
Kissing me,
kissing after hers.
Amazing.
Yes.
I love you Julia [inaudible].
Julia windmills.
I just wanted to send you a little message and tell you that meeting with you.
It was one of the,
one of the best,
a few minutes of my life.
Uh,
you know,
something's
been sitting heavy on my mind.
Uh,
when you,
when you mentioned something about wanting to get back with your ex don't,
which in the past,
believe me,
I know,
I know.
Don't look in the past cds,
cds,
fans back here
every,
every square inch of him and it never,
and never looked back.
Let's go full throttle.
Ciao.
There's a crown mold into the sealants.
This hand gesturing too that he does the Blm owns the ceilings.
All is Shariah Juliet receiving Christmas.
Julia,
submit the morning.
when I was at the Grammercy Julia,
me again,
Joe.
Look,
I just wanted to let you know,
I heard what you had to say on the Todd and Christine,
one of the best moments
and I wanted to get you a gift and the light of the holiday season,
the basket I build,
the wine I built,
I built these Christmas tree trimmings,
come from an undisclosed location somewhere in north central.
I call it the cabin of terrors.
And I,
Josh Potter,
I wish you the merriest of holiday seasons and I hope you enjoy Christmas full
throttle.
Wow.
She managed to get creepy too.
I know.
I think oddly it,
I think women tap into something that guys,
because the guys would you believe,
and then you really see like that the woman is flipping what she's said
experienced before.
This is because we've all had the guy,
the Joe and this Mary.
You know,
it's funny.
When I was,
uh,
when I was meeting fans after my second show at Gramercy theater,
I meet fans just cause I'm a personality champ.
Like people like my personality,
I don't know.
Some guy,
some guy goes,
we built this theater for you.
God Damn.
And I love this thing.
Open up your and your arms.
Yeah.
There's another one.
Good morning,
uh,
just wanting to say hi.
I can't stop thinking about you when your beauty.
So I just wanted to show you,
I built us a little gingerbread house.
Everything you see here,
I built a little gingerbread.
Yeah,
a little gingerbread Joe.
That's the other thing is this amazing emphatically making it clear that cause
it,
and he also,
what he says in that video,
he says,
uh,
you,
you know everything you see here.
I built and then he goes,
that's the kind of manager getting,
so he's letting me know like you're getting a fucking guy.
That's more than handy.
Right.
I can,
I can really,
I can build you a home.
You're getting a lot of free stuff here.
Here's the trade.
Right,
right.
You know a better house,
right?
Yeah.
I got,
I can do all this stuff for you.
You can make my babies.
Yeah.
I went
off to pay a contractor.
That's the best part.
This is all free labor.
Exactly.
I am a contractor.
Yeah.
Leaning on me cause we got to lean
on me a little gingerbread Joe.
I love this.
You leaning on me because we got to lean on each other for support.
I also built a little room and you in the eye.
I love this.
This one might be my favorite.
That was looking at you.
Yeah,
like we got it.
That's the message we've got to support each other.
Like things over count.
This girl's my favorite gingerbread house and we can hide all of the dead bodies
in maybe your ex boyfriend.
I really think that we should go full throttle.
If you don't agree it might be stabbing myself in the heart with the candy cane.
Kelsey Kelsey,
I love you and I love your facial hair.
The Gut t is a horrendous goatee is the 90s too.
Joe is also not fashionable.
Yeah,
that's pretty good.
Oh God.
Good Morning Julia.
Just wanted to say hello the Grinch.
Yeah.
And uh,
I'll tell you that you meet you yesterday.
Nice and full makeup.
Probably the best day of my wife.
Look at that.
And it's amazing.
Now you see behind you I've made with my bare hands in that child.
Can you deal with me?
So the kind of guy you're going to yeah.
To you truly have a,
have a merry Christmas.
I love you Julia.
Ciao.
See Ya.
I think guys up.
That's amazing.
Makeup.
The guys dressed like the grudge for real.
He's performing well.
He's clearly a performer.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Including this child,
Julie.
Oh my gosh.
Just as a reminder,
this holiday season,
I'm watching you.
He's the Elf on the shelf.
Elf on the shelf.
Good morning,
Julia.
Andre.
Andrew,
it's Christmas time.
Julia,
I want to let you know,
I built this for you cause I'm very,
very good at building things.
I built this gingerbread house for you,
Julia.
I built it for you.
Please come please.
I built it for you,
Julia.
Watch checked it.
Julia,
check this out.
Okay.
That's what I do,
baby.
We can live in that gingerbread house if you want.
I promise you that.
Think lifted on chapstick,
the chapstick.
I love you,
Julio.
Merry Christmas.
Giulia,
the kiss that gets me at the,
here's the thing,
gene,
that all the audience.
Yes you,
I think you sent me.
No,
she sent me a message and then she sent it to you,
but she sent me a message when I was,
we were going back and forth after last week and I was like,
you know you were grade and she said she had fun doing the interview and you
know some of her friends listen.
She goes,
oh,
there is one more video.
I was jamming with her on Instagram and I go,
thank you for doing the show.
You did.
Amazingly,
usually the audience is gonna love it.
And she goes,
well just,
you know,
I have some other videos I have to go check in my other phone,
give me a few hours,
I'll be right back.
And this is not a bit,
because I know people would who listened to this show regularly be like,
they're setting us up for a joke.
No,
this is not.
No.
So on bated breath,
I'm waiting at lax airport to board a flight and I keep refreshing my day and
you hit me up.
But when you tell me that's what it was,
I messaged her
video and she's like,
yes,
I'm looking for it.
And she said,
um,
she goes,
my,
like after she got more comfortable with the craziness of it,
right?
That her and her friends,
yes.
Hit him up once.
So what it was.
So she sent me two videos and she goes,
so my friends and I were kind of trying to bait him into making another video
for us,
for me,
for Julia.
And this is what he sent.
Yeah.
So they were trying to get him to be tacked to fool a little bit more.
Cause I like eventually she and her friends were just having a great time with
it cause it's,
you know,
mortifying.
Yes.
So
to be able to bring to you,
this has never been seen anywhere else except for Julius phone.
So it might be Joe seen it but that's it.
So this is,
you know,
you've seen the first one.
You've seen the one in the car the next day.
My flour.
But this is actually,
I'm so excited.
I can't,
I can't even handle it.
The video that no one has seen.
Never before seen Joe footage show footage back to Julie.
All right,
here it is.
See I'm half asleep on the couch.
It disappointed you got to be wrapped around your finger.
Cute.
But that's all you get.
I'm exhausted.
Blah.
Ah,
ah,
there it is.
So gross on so many levels.
A little more understated though than the other one.
He's tired and he's engaged now.
He thinks like if there's a little something going on,
we didn't have to be as put on,
here's what I don't like about this one is more disturbing because he's trying
to be sexy.
Yes.
And he's like,
I'm just laying down Pat Patton,
the chest get me all tired right now.
Jewels.
Yeah.
Like he's about to whip his peanut out and he's about to frantically masturbate
it again.
See,
I'm half asleep on the couch.
Disappointed you got me wrapped around your finger,
but that's all you get.
And I'm exhausted.
Always put the kisses big on those kisses.
My favorite is the playful laugh.
It's like,
yeah,
uh,
it's so cringe.
Got me wrapped around your finger.
Okay.
She's,
I imagine the dialogue being like,
which will give me wrangle it.
You,
I promise.
Julie's like,
send me another video.
Come on please.
And he's like,
Oh,
I'm tapped to run your finger.
You did that like Coy Mike.
Yeah.
Sexy time.
That's,
that's what I'm saying.
Like,
he's like,
oh,
she's like,
send me another video.
Come on,
try it.
Try and bait him probably.
And then he was like,
all right,
but I'm going to make it sexy.
We also said this one is like,
yeah,
it's like,
Ooh,
I just got home.
Yeah,
I have a lot left in the tank.
I'm all sweaty,
but I'm thinking of you to Wah Wah.
And it's dark in there.
It's poorly lit.
So He's like,
I'm just laying in the doc.
I feel like those are all things you like you do to children,
not to people you were romantically interested in.
What do you mean the children go ma?
Yeah.
Not to it.
Or Oh,
you're serious about like,
or want to be,
hey,
I'd like to take you out sometime.
Wow,
you got me wrapped around your finger.
He said it's like a kid.
Like I'll do anything for you to say that to an adult is weird.
So,
but just so you know,
Julia herself also,
um,
has had fun with this,
with her friends.
So that's what we learned is that Julia's friends,
like,
you know,
you guys have been submitting these hilarious Julia videos.
They've been doing it,
sending them to her.
So she sent us a cut of that to Julia.
Good morning.
Good morning,
Julia
Child.
Julia right there.
That's why Joe,
uh,
for those of you just listening,
we have Juliet giving her shit.
She's giving her
beautiful as good night to Joe.
Ciao baby.
Can Joe.
Yeah.
What a perfect end to this whole thing.
That is great.
She's so for those,
we just listening.
Julia is blonde.
She's got long blonde hair,
Brown eyes.
Beautiful.
She's a beautiful girl.
Yeah.
So that's a reason.
There's a reason she followed her into a parking lot.
If you were imagining a pig.
She is not.
No,
she's great.
She's sweet and lovely person.
Yeah.
That is so funny.
And then a Glazer's Joe's next message.
Oh Man.
That's what he wants to say in this last video.
I know,
but he dialed it back to like,
oh,
look at,
look at what you've done to me.
Ah,
ah,
I miss you Julia.
Um,
look at what you've done to me.
What does this say right here?
Someone said that their boyfriend mix up the flower delivery.
Uh,
he must be cheating with me on his sidekick.
Julia,
what's this mean?
I got a Christmas flower delivery and I always thinking,
wow,
it's so beautiful.
But who is Julia?
Julia?
This is the kind of man you're getting full travel.
Who is Julia?
That's so hilarious.
That's funny.
Your Morning Julia Mon and um,
all right,
our guest is here.
Why don't we step away for a moment and look what you've done to me.
Come right back.
You got me wrapped around your finger tight.
We'll be right back.
Okay.
We're back from our break.
You never heard and we are joined now by our guests.
Um,
a,
a friend of ours,
a comedian,
a podcast or an actor,
a working actor.
I just went on some of those people go.
I'm an actor,
a working voiceover accurate as well.
Mr. Adam Ray.
Thanks for
here.
Very warm wolverine.
Former Wolverine.
Right?
What's not drop that stat.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh,
it's okay man.
It's a lot of ex main characters.
Don't get there,
Charlie.
Talking about University of Michigan,
my bad.
Oh Shit.
I wish my mom wishes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
towards fan.
Well,
yeah.
Not that I wasn't a theme park character.
That's true.
Yeah.
The beat is,
oh,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Not the Hollywood boulevard though.
Like actually inside the theme,
the theme park and not that I want to knock the guys that cruise the boulevard
with like peanut butter shoes and stuff,
but like I imagine those guys I think got it really bad because they're trying
to like a universal,
people will know you're supposed to be there.
That's right.
Boulevard.
People were like,
all right,
I was looking to go check out,
you know,
Ripley's believe it or not and I accosting me for six bucks.
You know?
How many people do you think are thrilled if there at Hollywood boulevard to
seat to see those people?
They're like,
oh,
that's awesome because that's Elmo sesame street now.
Yeah,
they're kind of,
they're delusional.
I saw kids there too.
Delusional types of up.
They just cancel other out and nobody knows what the fuck's I think so.
I think they're probably really pumped it.
I think a lot of the tourists that go there are just like,
they want to soak up every piece of that street.
Isn't it exciting hearing this voice in your ears?
Oh man,
that's Tequila weed and just x men stories.
I feel like I only have this voice after a rough night voice.
Great Voice.
By the way,
Adam figure Adam's in the more like that,
that level of base he has.
There's times where I wake up and I'm like,
oh I should do voiceover.
Like it sounds that Alec Baldwin.
Yes.
So wait,
so you were one of those costume people and so what's the worst part about,
we prefer face character,
but it's okay.
You,
I mean how fucking free tickets.
What's that?
It was hot.
It must've been so hard.
This like Spandex,
you know,
muscly suit with the fake abs to fake chops.
The fake fangs.
Actually one in there.
One summer my boss who was like a former Disney princess turned head of the
characters.
I won't say her name on this,
Jenna,
but she was like,
kind of kind of the worst and like,
because she kind of took it out,
like just had a sense of entitlement and she pulled me in one summer and,
uh,
and you know,
I,
uh,
look,
I could be in better shape.
And at this time I felt like I was in pretty good shape even for being a fake
fucking theme park character.
And I'm like,
you're giving me fake abs,
so you're already telling me I don't got to do a ton of work on my own,
but I was fine.
And she pulls me in.
She goes,
hey.
So,
um,
I just,
uh,
you know,
we're a,
we're a universal,
people come in,
they want to meet Captain America at Spiderman and Wolverine.
And I go,
yeah,
it's awesome.
Right?
Fucking people think that we're the real people.
This is crazy.
And she goes,
yeah,
and you are.
And so I just would be great if maybe you just took a couple of weeks off to
just a firm up a little bit just to hone up,
just get those arms really wolverine.
I'm like,
I don't even think that's a real term.
He's like,
get a little,
uh,
you know,
just jacked up.
You're seeing do Jackman like that.
So I'm like,
you know that,
um,
like the guy who is captain America has a bumper sticker on his Escalade that
says nobody's ugly after 2:00 AM right.
None of us are the real guys.
Right.
But they just,
uh,
you know,
there was this like,
attitude of like these kids think you're,
and they did like,
and I didn't know shit.
Uh,
like they would,
you know,
every other day like,
what's wolverines favorite food?
And I would always joke about this because I would just be like to make
characters laugh and they were always chastise me for being,
trying to be funny.
The wolverines not funny because they'd hear me being like,
you know what's wolverines favor to food?
And I was like potato salad.
And she was like that.
How long,
how long would you have this Gig?
Maybe four or five years.
That's a long,
that's a long,
this was,
yeah,
this was after 2000 cause I was a tour guide at universal studios first on the
trim.
I make up facts all the time.
And this was like when you first got here?
Yeah,
I got it in 2001 went to acting school,
USC and then 2003 my sophomore year I was like,
I need a summer job.
Um,
and so tour guide was cool.
I don't want to,
you know,
I went with a buddy of mine wanted to do it.
He was like,
we've come with me just to the audition.
And then he didn't get,
he was like his dream to like tell people that that's jazz.
I was like his dream and then he got it.
But just so people know who've never been to universal studios.
So they take you on a tram and the train takes you through all the attractions
at universal but housewives and Dolly Parton House,
the psycho house opened with desperate housewives to universal studios and see
where it [inaudible] hey blowjobs gives a shit.
Right,
because you did you get like,
that's what I would say on the tour to
the wild whatnot.
Well,
there was the tank where Kramer swam and Seinfeld,
um,
what else do the,
uh,
was a
three week training course.
They give you a binder and I was in a fraternity in college at the time,
sort of lock myself in my frat during parties and memorize,
you know,
hours of material because you had to no other facts for the certain stops.
And then if you've got stalled in the summertime,
like backed up champions to get like six deep and you'd be waiting to go into
the earthquake,
you've got five deep.
So you'd have video clips.
Oh,
before they bought him video clips to play,
you had to just have stalled material.
So that's when I would start doing standup and doing like when flex some of this
open mic material on this and uh,
and you know,
some of it will go over.
Well I love,
by the way,
the journeys of people,
like all of us habit that they tried to do show Biz.
You have,
don't you like looking back and be like ours universal tour guy.
It was funny.
Wolverine,
like all these different was a cop two I hosted the fear factor live show there.
It got projectile vomited on,
said what the fuck in front of 1200 kids boss chewed me out.
He's like,
what are you doing?
1200 kids vomited on.
Yeah,
go.
What'd you want me to say?
Is that all you got?
Bring it on.
He's like,
you fucking said what the fuck 1200 kids.
And it was still going to do cause like it's such bullshit stents.
You're like,
all right,
when these guys were going to put them up on these,
uh,
B,
these flat beams and a,
and when I say go and then side effect goes go goosh the bottom drops out and
they put,
they're attached to this wire.
So I'm like,
but there are dads do a wire.
And I started improvising what time I go.
So there's no real danger of,
so what are we actually doing here?
And My boss is like,
you can't keep vamping on the script.
And so they would drop and they're hanging.
And then it's just like,
who can hang the longest without freaking out?
But then they have to eat actually a fear factor concoction like they would on
the show and it'd be like,
you know,
I don't know beaver twats and like pickle juice and um,
uh,
you know,
old milk and this one guy,
damn,
it's just projectile vomited on me and I'm literally,
I'm facing the crowd ago.
Come on everybody,
let's pump up the fear of whatever the bullshit,
you know,
give it up for Steve.
And they just,
I remember turning back to him and he just looked at me and just,
that was it.
And I was like,
what the fuck man?
And I heard half gasp and half like laughter.
Uh,
so that lasted a couple months.
How much do you make?
50 to 50 a show for the fear factor shows certain that's actually really good.
Certain guys would do five or six shows a day and kill it.
Lou's brother,
the blues brothers guys were making like 55 his show,
it's great.
Marine was like 22 an hour.
Your Mc like as an MC at the club.
We were really learning tour guy was shit though.
And that's why I was like,
I gotta I gotta get promoted.
How much boring,
how much for the tram?
The Tram House.
I'm curious about the tram cause that's actually is quite a skill.
It is.
That should have been the most,
but like you have to accumulate a certain amount of hours to get a pay bump.
So I think when I started it was like eight 50 an hour,
which by the way,
for our shows a day now that's not enough.
And three week training and then uh,
and then uh,
I mean it was bonkers.
God Damn abuse is what it is.
And also I was like,
make it a pretty fun,
there's a lot of tour guides and just do the bare minimum.
And they do the written jokes like,
you know,
uh,
for the jaws like,
oh Steve,
yeah guys,
we have to,
our friend Steve,
wait,
Steve,
get out.
Oh well the,
I guess this will be as less swim or you know,
but I would like actually stand up.
Take my sunglasses off,
freak the fuck out.
I met a girl cry,
I'm like my third tour because like fucking dumb acting student fresh out of
college.
I'm like,
this is an acting exercise.
Sure,
sure.
And I committed and I was like,
there's a fucking shotgun.
And she started balling
universal and should go to the Kiddos.
They got to Harry Potter world.
They're now when did you go to sc?
Yeah.
That's hard to get into that school for acting.
I mean,
yes,
I auditioned for,
cause you know,
my sat scores were shit.
I had a pretty good GPA,
some extracurricular stuff.
But then,
and then when I went to the admissions people,
they were like really pray and that juice stuff,
they didn't say it like that,
I'm paraphrasing,
but they were like,
you know,
diversity and all that.
And uh,
and then I wanted,
you know,
it wasn't totally sure if I want to do full on because in the BFA,
which I was in
a lot of shoes on the shelf,
you know,
rabbi,
how'd you get my rabbi?
Soundbite from the end of my bar Mitzvah.
I was like,
that's life.
Yeah,
you're a man.
It was congrats.
Give it up to mother fucking mother fucker.
Yeah,
my aunt goes,
I knew that was his name.
And so,
uh,
and so I auditioned because they were like,
you have a better chance if you get into the acting school then they'll tell the
school you have to take them cause we're taking them.
So the BFA is like,
you know,
class from nine to six better teachers more.
Um,
it's just a more rigorous program,
you know,
and so auditioning for that and then I got in and got it.
And because I don't think I would have otherwise the mean average sats do the
sat average I think of my incoming freshman class was like 15,
20.
Mine was like 11,
10 spare tonight.
Is it,
I mean a lot of time I was like cat is to,
kitten is fig,
Newton is the futon.
And I'd be like probably futon
dumb,
dumb fucking t those I second guess myself all the time.
I would get in my head,
put all the pressure on.
I just think the Jews a great
good killing it with those men.
I don't think you should stop doing it.
Your fingers always in the right place.
Do you know,
do you know about this Joe Juliet stuff?
Do you know about this?
No.
I know about your Garth,
that stuff,
which okay is maybe like,
and this is why you guys are so prolific and incredible on his Instagram.
Go ahead and the clips you post of them are just so spot on and,
and I love like worst and some people it just like as soon as you posted I was
like,
I get exactly what you're talking about.
The guys just,
and eventually what's so great about it,
I don't see it stopping anytime soon.
You're going to get them in here.
Well I hope so.
I swear to God you're going to get here.
I guarantee he's a fan of comedy.
Who knows what he likes.
He could be a big carrot top guy or like maybe it's like that Bonnie hunt show
needs to come back.
You know,
he doesn't like being made fun of.
I'm sure.
Well yeah.
So the comments,
his comments like that,
I don't mean like one or two.
Like I'm saying of these like 3000 right here.
Are they trolling them card?
Oh boy.
Well that's what you get for being the biggest selling act of all time.
Right.
I know.
It's like if you're going to be that big dude,
you gotta roll with it.
The youtube comments are probably a plenty,
you know,
like just roll with it.
Roll with it,
man.
Isn't that one of his songs role with controlling or what?
You know,
here are the comments on his latest posts.
Top comment does miss you with,
oh my God,
look at these comments.
Hashtag try it out.
Yes.
You got everything that you see in this house.
I built Giulia.
That's the kind of man you're good throttled jeans up and this is all Wyoming
correction last so much longer.
Especially during anal that,
well that's just like you learn that in the fifth grade.
So that's just like
I was explaining to people.
They're like,
it's from a podcast
with the income at conversations or maybe some of the best things the Internet
provides.
You know where people then who don't know each other like did,
I'll tell you what's going on.
I know.
You know what I'm saying?
This person said,
I'm so torn and pretty sad.
We'd,
so Garth,
do you think one day you're just going to be reading these comments and all of
sudden you're just going to see below like,
and rock 29 just going to see Garth knows 62 like,
you know,
I don't find this shit that funny.
I was going to integrate his,
his say I submitted a false,
somebody on the marketing team has definitely been like,
look,
you guys are too big to for him to not know that this is happening,
uh,
at,
and at least they're probably like a couple of assholes.
Just let it go.
You know that to other breaking it down the shore for sure.
And I,
and I'd like to say this,
we have no ill will towards Garth.
We're just having fun and it's all in fun.
It's a universe what it is too.
It's a great example in like,
dude,
don't take yourself so seriously.
Yeah.
Especially when you're a country rock music superstar.
When I saw Celine Dion in Vegas,
and I've always said that sentence a couple of times out loud,
you should limit it.
My buddy had tickets when I was out there,
uh,
for that,
um,
this Vegas comedy festival,
which was crazy because the night before I'd gambled with a sickler and Josh,
Adam Meyers and Bert Kreischer and we'd all,
we're playing roulette.
Bert didn't remember it,
which is insane because he instigated,
he instigated us winning all at ton of cash.
We put down,
I think a hundred.
It was like,
let's put it on a hundred before we whatever on black.
And then we won.
And they were like,
oh yeah.
And then bridges look through when it goes,
let it ride led,
right.
And we were like,
yeah,
we did it again.
One again,
did that five times and why and then sickle when I was like,
I mean maybe we just fucking stuff away this point.
Like that's extra cash.
And then he said,
let it ride one more time.
And it's the most racist comedian.
True.
You let it ride again in one and then left.
And then,
uh,
and then the next day we were like,
dude,
I'm going to say it's on my breakfast.
And I was like,
hey man,
thanks for that extra laundry money.
And he was like,
we talking about,
I was like,
Ugh,
let it ride your catchphrase of the night.
And he was like,
man,
I just rugged,
I don't even black.
And now it's good.
It's usually a sign that,
but it was so fun.
But so the next time my buddy's like,
I'm supposed to go to Celine Dion with my,
um,
with my wife and she's sick.
She's like,
do you want to go?
I was like,
I dunno man.
He goes,
I got a blunt.
I was like,
that sounds fun.
So we go,
we were like fifth row,
first of all,
she's unbelievable,
but it's one of those Vegas acts and one of these artists that has done probably
hundreds of thousands of shows that she,
um,
she's like,
hey man,
this is also an opportunity for me to spread my wings comedically.
And,
uh,
you Caesar's as a giant open mic and pump out a little standard material,
Celine style.
She was like,
every opportunity was a song.
She was like in between two and she'd be like,
this is my backups.
My backup guitar player won.
He's been with me for 20 years.
He's been with me,
but one of the years.
And I was like,
well,
just on the set list,
what the fuck's going on?
And then she came out in a yellow dress at one point and she goes,
look at me.
I'm so Yaddo.
Um,
so yeah,
it'll yellow and I'm just like in the back,
like no one's disputing the color.
What the fuck?
And then she just goes,
I'm like,
and it stops and does like a turn to the camera and goes,
I'm like Celine Dijon.
And everybody lost their fucking minds,
including me,
because I had reached like the peak high and I was like,
I'm not above a good condiment joke.
Yeah,
that's good.
And uh,
but every,
and then she talked for 20 minutes and then you go there.
In my inner being,
like pick it up,
pick it up,
you're doing too much.
Stand up.
She would call it stand up and then she'd go into my heart will go on.
Or that's the way it is.
And you just forget about everything.
She just done,
you know,
it's amazing.
Show.
Unbelievable whole gone.
She's elevating.
There's fake rain.
Thought it was fake.
Look pretty real to me.
Maybe the,
we was great,
but she's just,
how does she fucking fly?
How does she sing without the accent?
Oh yeah.
That is a great,
I should have.
I should have raised my hand and asked that,
but I think
it went away when you sing.
I've heard that.
I think they have to train themselves.
The train the accent out cause you can't hear it.
Yeah.
The singing people train accents.
You can train
it out.
Yeah.
You hear other British pop singers will have sound.
No accent.
Yeah.
In their song.
God's action stays pretty consistent though,
doesn't it?
Does he do a little bit of a,
you know,
in between,
I know it's been to a show now.
Somebody offered me this though.
They said,
they said if you were given tickets,
you go and if you enjoyed it,
would you admit it?
And I was like,
I have to say yes to both.
Yeah.
I wish I would go.
I would say that I had a good time if I did.
Yeah,
for sure.
I wouldn't go into like a sour post that would be like,
yeah,
it's not that we're not ripping on his music or his talent.
Curious about people that tour to that size of an audit,
like even the wiggles on mine now.
What are they doing that I'm not doing you,
by the way,
the sleep thing,
because it makes me realize if you're super famous and a singer,
they all do this because it's your fans.
You get to see what their real sense of humor is like.
And you get to see who was legit funny because the audience will laugh at
whatever.
Well that's right.
More saline,
saline Deshaan great.
But I mean it just was angry.
All that between the song like
that they all do.
I've been to shows where you were like,
I wish she would just sing the next fucking,
and then there's legit.
I'm sure you know people who are pretty funny.
I Bet Dolly Parton's pretty funny.
I bet that's true.
Yes.
I Bet Mumford and sons not,
but I bet to all this.
But that was,
what's the best though.
She can't do any better than Dolly Parton now.
Do you think she's a lesbian?
Oh No.
There's stories floating that she's been married to the same guy that ever was
not a jeopardy question.
This lesbian wants to lesbian.
He never heard this though,
that she has,
uh,
like Jolene was written about some woman that she loved or something.
I don't know enough Dolly's stuff.
The only note around,
very close or very informed of don of Dali.
So I could be,
I could ask,
I don't want to say,
I'd like to know the truth.
Let's find this out.
Okay,
we'll find out.
She also seems like one of those journey,
you know,
artists,
it's just like done it all seen it all could have stories where it's like
there's one time I was on a flat to Burbank,
we ended up in Mongolia.
Next thing you know I'm scissoring a couple,
you know,
ESL students,
and you're just like,
all right,
let's rock and roll lifestyle.
And you know,
I saw her in Atlanta once in an airport and the airport in Atlanta.
Cool.
Did you go to her?
She famous people do.
Yeah.
No I leave him.
I would only ever,
ever do it to one person,
which is how we're starting because I love Howard Stern.
I fucking,
that's who I would do it too.
Even though I've done it too.
The goo goo dolls.
But
he did say to take a picture with him cause I
rest in peace.
Semper fi.
Brad Pitt.
I don't give a fuck about,
no,
I don't care about,
that's all.
I did that interview with Larry King and he was like,
yeah,
who are you?
Like
if you ever been starstruck.
And I was like yeah,
by rappers.
And he was like,
what?
And I was like,
he gets angry.
I go out and run in.
What's around?
I mean,
I think,
uh,
I think some athletes are cool.
Like where I've been like,
oh,
you know,
I love sports.
So I've been like,
but I don't think it would be like,
like maybe Jordan would make me do that because,
uh,
no,
no.
I mean I would be like,
that's cool.
Yeah.
I'm Greg Louganis for sure.
Dude,
you swam with it.
But I feel like if it were,
I know that I've,
I've been actually at a loss for words with different rappers that I've just run
into him because that's just,
I feel like it's,
it's more rooted in childhood,
you know?
Was that in style Jea?
And you're like,
this person defined an era for me.
I get kind of freaked out by it.
Well,
you're Tyson stories,
like one of the greatest stories I would break down for Ben.
Thank you.
Thank happened.
And I,
you know,
crazy broken down daisy.
Also the amount of layers to that story is just like,
I remember,
I think the first time I heard you say that the icehouse before you taped it and
I was just like,
I can't even believe like when it should have maybe stopped.
I was like,
there's more to this.
It was right.
Yes.
Did you have to,
and you know what the layer,
the layer of it that I ended up telling the uh,
a condensed version.
No,
I ended up telling the followup story because I realized that the story ends
with a phone hanging up.
Like that's how the bit,
and that's how the special ends.
Yes.
And people would always be like,
did he ever,
did you ever,
did he ever show up?
Yes.
And he did.
And so I would tell that story.
Right.
It took you a little bit to go,
oh,
I need to add that to it.
Yeah.
Well,
what happened was since it was at the end of a special,
what I realized was like everyone was asking me about that story and I was like,
well,
I know I can tell you the rest of the story.
So I put that as a bonus on that.
But then the thing that happened that really doesn't get the attention because
of the way it is,
but I put it on Instagram because that's the only place I knew to share it.
I get a year later,
a photograph that this guy,
multiple photographs and he's like,
so I was at the airport in Pittsburgh and the story,
but I tell was about being on a flight from la to Pittsburgh and he's like,
check this out and it's these photographs and Tyson is posing with people and
it's,
it's coming off that flight and he's holding my DVD.
So it really tied in.
Oh,
Angela demised it on Instagram.
People were like,
Oh,
this Photoshop.
I'm like,
no,
I just gave it to him.
Like it's like the thing I just gave them.
So you see him like holding it,
which I always thought was,
you know,
a trip,
right?
Yeah.
It's like actually,
yeah.
And it,
and it totally validates the story.
But yeah,
I mean,
meeting,
you know him was insane.
Jordan.
I feel like it would be way less personable,
but I would still be like,
oh,
I wouldn't know what to say to him.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think of like anybody else,
uh,
Kim deal of the pixies.
That'd be great.
But you forced
me to go up to her.
I never would have let her go up to her.
I knew what that meant.
I knew what it meant or,
yeah.
So I was like,
should I say AV?
Cause if it would have been like that's somebody from that band and I know she
doesn't care.
Yup.
But when I,
when she was like,
oh my God can do all I see are like rocking,
like it's like a crazy,
I was like,
yes,
you should.
I go,
you're never going to be so nice to me.
She was the next her teeth,
she picked her.
She was like,
I had a um,
sitting outside diner.
She was like,
yeah.
well I'll take a picture.
And I was like,
yeah,
hold on.
Just let me know.
She was tuned to show.
Yeah.
Okay.
Who else?
So,
first of all,
most importantly,
who's got a bigger dog shack or Jordan?
Go ahead.
Well,
I was told by someone who met Jordan wants that his hands are like,
is it that seemed like I was going to be like the date there's got Jordan's got
the car that his hand is like gigantic,
gigantic.
I feel like I'm,
it's usually right.
People go,
what size shoe you.
Oh yeah.
He must be fucking with that penis,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
which isn't always true though.
I mean,
as a Dick Detective,
I can say that is not that card sent true.
I mean,
I'll tell you this.
No,
you're right.
We got the opening theme
every Tuesday.
Oh my God.
We study them.
We know these things.
Yeah.
No,
but you know what I'm saying.
We got it all started because she was like,
one time she was like,
well,
that guy's really tall,
so he's got a huge Dick.
I go,
I don't think that's always the case.
Yeah.
Left in little dude.
I haven't seen short guys a big decks.
I have not seen that.
I got to have new pictures in the house.
Yeah,
there's definitely short guys with my,
um,
my cohost Bradley Williams,
a test that he,
you know,
is,
uh,
he's,
he's a little guy packing.
Okay.
But also,
you know,
the small,
the small hands and everything like pretty sure,
sure it's bigger.
But,
um,
but I think with the big hand thing,
I don't know,
I think there was some truth to that,
but also shack,
like I just can't imagine that that thing doesn't also,
I was just like an extra leg.
It's,
yeah.
He could have on large Dick that is not proportionate to how big he is.
Oh yeah.
You would think that's a small Dick because he's such a proportion of girls see
it and they go,
wow,
I'm saying an eight inch Dick on him.
Eight inches is definitely well above that.
Fine.
Yeah.
And then get into a lot of,
and you'd be like,
what's that thing you got?
You need tweezers.
What's going on there?
But it's actually a d,
You know,
but I'm asking you guys,
what do you think's got a bigger one?
That's right.
You asked Shakeel [inaudible] George is a graceful,
I mean,
Jordan globalized the sport,
so I feel like his dick probably even just grew from just like the world
recognizing thank you for what you're doing for the sport.
The natural,
the universe,
universe,
big Dick Energy in federal.
That's Neil degrasse Tyson type shit or like,
yeah,
but he,
maybe it's the secret.
Right.
But just being like,
if I take Gatorade,
the China,
maybe my Kako right.
Follow suit.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Right.
But I think just being the greatest,
I feel like he's got to be,
I think so.
That's right.
I'm talking about stature.
I'm going to go.
But you said Chuck Keeler you said you know somebody that's,
I shy Kiehl's,
so you know.
Oh Jesus.
Well,
there's stories of like hose who are like,
he ain't,
he ain't got all that.
Yeah.
But also video hose and stuff.
Oh really?
Yes.
Whole videos was very,
videos are like,
his dig ain't all that you think like,
do they know it was just like lead them leaving his house or is that,
I'm just posting on Instagram.
They've even written about it.
Wow.
Sort of book like tells.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I mean,
you know,
these are bold move by the way to write a book after like fucking track Hoe
you're big like how many chapters is that?
I wanted my uterus to fall out and nothing happened.
Yeah.
It could have now hands,
you know,
the,
the story in the NBA now is,
uh,
what's his name?
Kwame Leonard.
Um,
am I saying his hands?
Have you seen the stories about that?
So there he was like getting some photo like after you know,
the after workout sometimes they'll all,
and people were like,
what the fuck is going on with his hands?
It turns out he has the largest hands in the NBA right now.
Dan.
He's a big guy,
but there's guys that are bigger and it's unnatural men and it actually for sure
affects the way you shoot.
Handle the ball where you bet,
dude,
look at,
I want to see if I can find this photo.
You'd be like,
Oh shit.
That is,
you know,
I'm sorry,
I'm going to the Rolodex of decks of my panties were back to the desk.
I'm trying to think of the hands,
the hands and Dick race.
Yeah.
And I think you're right.
It's not the hand to Dick,
right?
It's not the hand.
It's not,
it's a general overall stature.
Do you think swagger can give girls that there's first of all indication that
no,
look at this NBA regulation,
basketball.
I mean his hands are huge.
Oh my God.
How do girls size up like from a dude,
whether they can try to get an idea,
like,
is that even a thing?
I don't think he feels pretty good.
It's got to be,
is that cool water?
Nope.
Tiny Dick.
Or like
there are guys who I thought,
Oh surely this is going to be a big dog and it's just not all backwards hat.
Like you just find something that he's convinced yourself.
This is what got it goes.
You are a mess Jersey under his Tux.
This is what got the story going.
This guy here,
like you don't see that there's actually like a ball basket ball in his hands
because he's just holding it.
That's crazy.
And you're like,
wait,
what?
What's going on there?
And,
um,
yeah,
it's like hands.
Yeah.
That's got to mean something,
right?
Yeah.
I mean this is a kid,
but still it's,
but then there's guys like Muggsy Bogues where you're like,
you know,
wait,
so I got distracted by the fix that you've,
you've seen hands like you're like,
all right,
this is,
these are going to be going in the Rolodex of Dick's.
Right,
right.
Hold on just a couple thousand hours to get through
this podcast,
bro.
Bro,
bro,
Bro.
Like Christina,
a second to think about on the sticks.
Okay.
By the way,
I want that to be the song they played people up to when they give the eulogies
at my funeral rub,
rub,
rub that as they walk.
Like they're like,
all right.
And now here's Mr Tangun is eighth grade PE coach
Adam was a sweet boy.
Brian.
It was,
you got to deepen your voice and have it sound like you've been smoking 10 packs
a day for 40 years and have your breath smell just the worst.
Ah,
no.
And then teach us to shoot underhand free throws.
No,
I'm going through my [inaudible] going on here telling you that there have been
shockers where I've been like,
this guy will have an average one,
and it was in that moment you're like,
oh,
this will be a normal guys.
Build is average.
It's just like a tall lean and then it'll be like underwhelming,
like highly underwhelming.
I've had that.
I've had modest,
like really insecure guys who you're tall and now no swagger,
but you're like,
that one's got a big one.
Oh,
just because you show on assuming about it.
Kind of meek,
but big stature.
Tall.
But then that one was big.
That one guy died at the biggest one and then did you that big sides?
You have quite some time for the holidays,
but that big one though,
you suspected it would be,
no,
I hadn't.
I don't know.
We're so we're talking about is,
well,
that's the thing.
We know you always hope.
Here's the thing,
it's like,
it is always hope.
You always want the best gift.
That's right.
Nobody goes like,
oh,
I hope like you know some,
I met my best friend gets the Barbie Princess car.
You're like,
no,
I wasn't
right.
Yeah.
That's the thing is you're always hoping it's gonna.
You'd never,
we really don't know.
It's a crap shoot every time.
Yeah.
I'm just saying that there's,
when I look back,
it really,
there really is no formula.
Yeah.
It's kind of like,
you know what it was,
but you're saying actually you're making the point that you can't,
it's irrespective.
Yeah.
And do you make a noise if you are like under like is there uh Huh?
No.
No,
but I've had the best moment in porn is,
oh geeze.
Yeah.
Feel when their light is,
you know,
what's the most,
the most disappointing Peter's I've had though me when they're real short and
fat.
Really personally,
that's not my jam.
We have the,
if the,
the Dick is short and fat,
what does that mean?
That doesn't tell the story of the,
I can't do it.
What's the,
I can't,
you're like,
this is too big.
That is not,
that is a story they buy.
It was,
it was not because of his dick size.
I thought you told me that.
It was like you're like,
this is too big.
This'll be damaging.
It wasn't because of that.
Oh No it was because I wasn't a kind of,
I wasn't into it like cause it doesn't look like it was going to fucking destroy
you.
That's gotta be a thing.
I feel like if I see one that's that big.
Yeah.
And that's like,
and you're,
you're in that world of like this is going to be a part of my evening and then
all sudden it's almost like you go to a restaurant and you're let me get this
size.
It's,
and they bring a real big one.
You're like,
I don't know if I can eat all that.
There is some,
there is some real equipment out there.
I've seen videos where I'm like if I was a chick and that thing pulled out,
I might be like,
oh there was a guy I'm like,
hold on cause I forgot about that one because I never,
we never did it,
but I did see it,
you know,
but that guy was small.
That guy was a guy with small stature.
You would never freaking now he was a Puerto Rican guy.
He was sure.
Anyway,
so yeah,
we never was it your race or racism made you not do it?
So maybe your next special,
I mean why wouldn't you do this big Puerto Rican down?
Why?
Because I was,
I was too sensitive.
Honestly.
It's because I'm not that kind of girl.
I couldn't do it.
Couldn't have,
I was trying and have a one night stand.
That's what I was trying to do.
Yeah.
And I,
I'd never done it before.
You are my first one night stand,
you know that.
So we ended up fucking marrying the one guy that I tried to do it.
I'm terrible.
You had you so you're not as,
or at least some booze involved.
Of course.
I'm joking.
I'm yes.
And then you're like,
you still go and I was like,
I can't do this.
This is not for me.
How did he handle that?
Not Well of course it didn't like it as mad and I was like fuck you.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
I'm the woman I called course you and like be like,
well maybe we just need to play a game or something.
That's usually when you hear just the tip.
Did you hear that a lot?
That no,
not that night but there was another Puerto Rican guy that tried that shit with
deacons or if you wait,
so the producers of Dick Detectives because how many Rican Puerto Rican guy and
I did not do it with him,
but he did try to just the tip me,
I swear to God
it was the,
it was during,
I was like college,
this is like around junior year and this guy did try to do it.
He goes,
no,
come on just,
and I was like,
you don't have a condom.
I'm not going to have sex with you.
Like,
and he's like,
no,
no dude,
this is the 90s when like they tell you that aids is rampant.
This is different Puerto Rican guy.
And how far did you get though?
I did not.
I did not fuck me because we'd have anything.
You know what I mean?
Don't you get started before you get out,
you're making out.
And then he's like,
come on man.
He's like trying to talk me into it.
And I was like,
no bro,
cause this is the night.
Like I said,
I was very nervous and that says tds and fucking aids and shit.
Yeah.
He didn't say just a tip.
You just say that phrase but it was that just the tip thing?
Yeah.
Just come on,
let me just,
let me just read through it.
Just feel that I've got a great urethra.
Yeah.
Why?
Why is the tip always been so like is that the best part now?
Because he thinks if he can get in and of course
you'll want the rest of it.
Just seeing who's agreeable.
Cause if you go,
come on just the tip.
And the girl was like,
all right,
you're like,
she's down.
She just wanted,
she just wanted to get a little pushback on it.
Your girl is very paranoid of disease and I couldn't do it.
Come on.
And you were like,
it's your voice.
I lost my voice.
Yep.
That's very rude.
Inconsiderate.
He's right there.
Yeah.
That's so rude.
Do you want to know where I saw some crazy Dick's recently.
At least it's insane.
And I post on Instagram and Instagram took it down.
Oh.
Um,
upgrading myself to a little first class seating.
Right.
Nice.
And uh,
always don't feed on Delta.
Got the hot towel,
got the weird cookie.
And um,
there's a guy two rows in front of me and it's dark.
It's a night flight.
Austin.
I see him on his iPad scrolling through.
I still,
I'm sorry,
phone,
I'm just kind of like look over it.
And also I'm just like,
oh,
those are dicks.
All those are,
those are butt's,
your butt's taking Dick's,
those,
their boobs.
And this guy is just going through an airplane.
This dude in the front row of the thing.
So like,
and he's just filing through as if he's got all these,
it's a gay person.
He had a wife right next to him.
She was,
um,
I don't know what ethnicity,
but she had a big garb on and he's scrolling through all these saved videos.
And at first it's just like black people fucking,
and then it's like,
uh,
just dicks Wa there's old men walking around flopping dicks.
It was this whole grab bag of like,
where are you thinking in third row,
second row.
And he's in first row to the left and I'm on the right at the window.
He's on the aisle first row and I'm right behind him on the aisle.
So I'm like diagonal.
So I'm like,
and I'm just like,
what is happening to just casually actually scrolling through,
like he's looking at menu items of the cheesecake for what you're doing when
you're next to me on your iPhone looking at fucking,
and he would stop on the weirdest videos and then all of a sudden like I would
never be,
I'm not,
see,
I'm too fucking paranoid and to,
I'm too private and personal to,
to do something like that publicly.
I look at crazy shit,
a alone,
but never in a public space.
I just be too paranoid.
Yeah,
no.
Also like what if like the stores is just all of a sudden you're so in your porn
world,
I would never
want the public shaming,
you know,
obviously like she'd have to say something or he,
right.
Well they should,
if you got kicked off for that you shut.
Yeah.
You,
you in there.
I took a video,
I posted it on Instagram and people were posting like,
yeah.
And uh,
cause I was just like,
you know,
and I even took like a little picture of this guy and was going to add that to
it.
And then a,
but Instagram took the video down after about 10 minutes,
read tons of comments on people.
Just,
I mean,
a lot of people being like this just gross.
Why did you post this?
And then we will still have it on your phone by the way.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you got to show it to me.
Of course,
Dick and butts on plane quick.
I was like,
oh,
of course.
Yeah.
Dixon Dixon Butts.
I'm saying,
do you know about the movie tip toes?
No.
Have you heard about it?
It was Kevin Bacon in it.
No.
But there's some big names in it,
uh,
to the eighties and nineties movie,
early 2000,
early 2000 [inaudible].
Right.
Uh,
educate me,
Gary Oldman's in it.
Love Gary Oldman.
I mean,
it doesn't get better than that.
It wasn't,
um,
and let's Gary Sinise is in the,
to the Gary Gary's.
Yeah.
Is there a movie that just got all Gary's in it?
Yeah,
I should pay do,
that's a really good question.
Gary's and who are the great Gary's Matthew mcconaughey,
isn't it?
Love that Gary,
Gary [inaudible].
Gary.
Oh,
Terry it the gay porn star.
Gary Oldman.
Okay.
I just want to,
I think we have,
so this is pretty exciting.
Um,
I'm sorry I'm pulling this up.
How did you become fascinated with this flick?
Uh,
because I didn't think it was real.
Those are the best.
We haven't even watched the movie.
We've just seen the trailer and the trailer doesn't seem real and the trailer is
real love that.
Um,
trying,
somebody made this a studio,
invested a lot of money.
Well,
you have mconnais,
McCombs spreads healing.
Brad Williams is your podcasting partner.
For those of you who don't know.
Yes.
What's your show called you about last night?
That last gas?
Yeah,
here it is.
Sorry.
Um,
which we need to get you on.
I would love to make that happen.
Maybe.
Maybe in the new year,
right?
Yeah.
I'll have to,
uh,
okay.
So here's,
this is a real trailer cause I know you're going to be like,
what?
This doesn't seem right else by the way.
I love movies.
Carolyn Steven's life together.
It was perfect
roles.
Yeah.
Like,
hey baby.
Hey,
low job.
And not yet.
There's one small problem.
Hi,
I'm rolling.
I'm his brother.
Which twins?
He can tear them apart.
I think you've got to let me know that everyone in your pants is images,
images,
Carolyn doors.
What afterwards bring them to.
Hey,
welcome.
I'm Steven.
There you are.
This is Steven's father Bruno and his mom Kathleen and over behind the bio
students
who could have prepared us for this.
Don't you think?
Battersby I'll never speak to cancer.
Just get it together.
Maybe I'm pregnant when the going gets rough.
It's only the size of your heart,
that big of a deal.
If a kid a door,
you not this great girl and you didn't tell her that her baby's probably got to
be a the door voice.
We also cute and cuddly discriminate against us.
Did bridges this and let me do the trailer for it.
Yeah.
How bad is the voiceover so bad?
This guy doesn't add studies,
was barely reading copy.
He's just like Mikaila is in it.
Then a midget shows up Becken sails freaked out.
She doesn't know if she gets stuck off a guy who brothers with the music,
the Vo for the,
for the trailer.
He's like,
they didn't know what would happen next.
Like it has a very not for it sounds like he was auditioning for the part and
they were like,
yeah,
we might give it to you yet.
Hey,
do we have any of the,
the uh,
demos from the auditions just top line it up.
We're not going to hire a real guy.
If he did
and he's got a little wild.
I never expected
Goldie Hawn.
My Nick can do what he wants to do.
Relationship.
What is this man doing?
A new about doing
Matthew.
Hey,
Gary Oldman.
Hot tubs in midgets.
Was that the ultimate title?
I'll walk down the aisle.
Oh yeah.
This guy sounds like he had demoed like a t-mobile employee.
What he's like when you show up to the store after five,
remember to put the cases back where you found them.
Makana Hayes heart.
Let's hope it's big enough.
He does keep this marriage going.
That's exactly it.
And here's,
here's his that can sales in it too.
She's great.
You're like,
okay,
now he's just giving personal.
Here's this,
here's the final.
But then you leave our admins a little man.
The final title now.
Ooh,
said Langley productions.
Probably present command performances from Kate Beckinsale.
Matthew mcconahey.
Nope.
And in the role of a lifetime,
it's one way of role of a lifetime whole lead to shit.
Brad
know about this.
I wish we would've played it for him when he was here.
I think it was.
It was after.
Oh my God.
Do you think,
wait a minute,
did bridges the midget have to change her name to bridge?
It's a little person.
You mean now?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
I Dunno.
Wait a minute.
How do you think now do you think in the pitch meeting guy and he's like,
oh look,
I'm very excited for this new movie you guys,
you know I've been loving to work with and sale at some point,
right?
Oldman John Fan.
No,
no.
Bigger fan of old man and they go,
we're going to say mcconahey for the trailer.
We'll talk about it.
I've never heard it pronounced that way either.
Right?
That was different.
You can't really see it but I can see it.
Wait,
so what's,
I mean are you going to have a viewing party?
Because I need to know does Oldman rip them apart because Kate's like,
I don't know it didn't you say at one point like,
I dunno if I can go through with this because they're about to get married.
They're about to,
but then all the sudden Dorf Oldman shows up and throws a curve ball into
Macanta Dick Gregory
and then she's like,
am I going to have a dwarf baby?
Does she,
is that a concern?
The major concern.
Whoa.
This is like very anti dwarf,
kind of feels like it kind of,
it is.
Uh,
yeah,
like couldn't make this movie.
Now here's the trivia in it.
So it's a good thing he didn't show it to bread cause that's like true nemesis.
Oh yeah.
Wait for real.
For Real.
Yeah.
We train them on it,
on Twitter and bread.
I Dunno.
Just like their God.
Yeah.
Is that why?
Maybe.
Yeah,
no,
I think maybe it's,
maybe it's one of those things where he was like,
I think Brad's people were too,
where he's like,
he looks up to the amps,
the envelopes,
loops.
So people were like,
[inaudible] is your guy.
And he's like,
don't tell me how to live my life.
You know,
he likes to,
I like whoever I wanted.
Yes.
Don't tell me who I have to idolize like that.
Yeah,
I agree.
But also I feel like maybe intake,
which gets a lot of parts,
I think that Brad would like,
oh,
sure.
Yeah.
Um,
here's some of the right now and I
MDB for tiptoes.
Director,
uh,
Matthew Bright was fired after you turned in his cut the whole,
the whole film was then re edited.
Yeah,
that's a great moment where he plays it for everybody and they just go,
do you think it's immediate where they watch it at the end of Oldman?
The last line,
let's just hypothesize.
Oldman just goes.
So I guess I'll just grab my shoes and leave.
Mcconaughey goes Shari.
But we're going to have a baby and he goes,
fine.
Fuck you.
Credits.
And they can just turns around and goes,
you're fired,
you're fired.
And then this is the good version.
This is the,
this was Rhea and Peter Dinklage said that the original director's cut,
which screen in Austin was gorgeous,
but the people who fired,
uh,
Matthew Bright ruin the movie who recut it?
Like what did,
I don't know cause I'd love to see what else he did.
Did he do like fried green tomatoes or,
um,
good point.
You know,
I see this again,
the trailer,
they're trying to make it into like a Romcom,
like a comedy.
And I have a feeling the way that it was shot was probably more respectful of
dwarves and of the story.
And then they were like,
hey,
you got to make this for the general audience.
You've got it.
Let's make this a wacky comedy.
And you're like,
but it's not funny.
I'm sort of wondering,
so what year was this?
Cause oh three.
It's not that we're,
you've been around for a while.
Like,
are we that throwing off that one could show up and all of a sudden enter the
family being the,
uh,
the like that reaction when the mother's like,
yeah,
that was great.
Like,
what are you telling me?
Are there black people?
She was really,
really react if a black too often walked in shoe.
Um,
here's some other of the trivia that's on the page.
Sure,
sure.
Gary Oldman kept his jeans extremely high end tire for the entire film,
uh,
to create the illusion of a small person after initial criticism.
Gary Oldman was quoted as saying,
just try it out grilled and said he was fired by his favorite musicians.
Garth Brooks in the four stroke gang.
Okay.
Oh,
this film has been held in high regard for its soundtrack,
including the original song.
Good mornings.
Really,
yet by gene mix,
ceiling fan
genes are everywhere.
They're everywhere are everywhere on the Internet.
So I asked you this,
um,
a while back before we jumped around that.
Who did you know who,
good morning Julia.
Well,
that referred to know,
so that referred to,
um,
something that's really blown up on this show,
which is a young lady named Julia One day was that the gym left the tanning bed
at the gym,
went to her car and a man followed her out of the gym and said her name.
And the reason he knew her name was because you sign in at the gym.
So he was like Julia,
Julia.
Oh No.
She was like,
her name is Julia.
Julia.
Well,
yeah,
exactly.
[inaudible] name is Julie.
Okay.
And he was like,
hey.
And she was like,
do I know you?
And the reason he knew her name was because he saw the sign and creepy.
Never thought that.
That is such an easy way.
It's like when kids used to wear names on their sweatshirts,
you know?
Absolutely.
Yes.
I did that as a kid and that's,
we'll put a pin in that story.
Well he,
so he followed her out and she was nice.
Like basically he,
she was like in a,
in a polite roundabout way was like,
I'm not interested.
Um,
but he was like,
let me get your number.
And she was holding her phone so she was like,
why don't you put your number in?
So like I have it.
So he put his number in and then dial his phone.
So he got her phone number.
But anyways,
she was like,
that's that.
She goes home and the next morning she gets this on her phone.
Good morning,
Julia made Joe.
Just wanted to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that meeting you yesterday and getting a look at you was probably one
of the greatest moments of my life.
You are so beautiful.
You don't know how beautiful you are to me.
I mean just,
you're gorgeous.
You're precious.
So it goes on.
It goes off in my mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with your ex boyfriend,
please erase him from your memory.
Don't ever go back in the past.
I know men in black light in there and I understand when you know you're trying
to find somebody and you go on dates and nothing compares to your rack.
It's a lot.
There is that better person out there with morphine.
Julia,
I promise you it is.
May Open up your heart.
Okay to make in your arms open up,
be highly aggressive.
The ocean style.
Get Out of my dreams,
get into my car.
It's,
it's nuts.
As he purposely given like the cribs tour in the background I'm like is he very
inconspicuous each other.
Good luck and I got a dope kitchen case.
You want to come over
all this myself,
the trim this goatee or let it grow more,
whatever you want.
And then he sent her a follow up video shortly that she respond to that or this.
No,
just want to say good morning.
Get you to know I could wear hats like this.
No nicknames yet.
Dude.
My soon to be my everything.
Holy Shit.
I have a great day.
Love.
Oh,
straining order table for one.
Just waiting on it now how many,
how many ones he sent?
Oh my God.
And this is,
you know,
and it's so stuff like that that I go,
Oh man,
like you know,
not that I don't feel bad when I hear these creeper stories from guys,
but it's like when you see video evidence you're like,
oh yeah,
like there was a girls dating in college.
I remember her,
she was at a bar and she gave a number to a guy because we were dating and she
was like,
I just felt bad.
And I was like,
don't do that.
Like there's these going to send you weird shit now.
And he did.
And a horse like she was terrified.
She was terrified.
But then like she eventually,
well like people started to send her videos of him like working out.
I could be workout buddies.
I think you need a spotter in life.
And the gym he got,
he got the hint and,
but like when he didn't seem like he would,
that seemed like a video web series ready to be made.
She probably has a certain point actually blocked him if I,
that's all it takes.
Right?
I'm sure.
Well she eventually got,
she thought it was funny after awhile.
Oh cool.
You know,
once you got some distance from it,
she got the first one.
She was so mortified that she didn't share with anybody cause she was like,
oh my God,
this is so bad.
And there's a thing he didn't seem,
he seemed like a kind of affable guy that was kind of like,
you're dumb.
Like almost like your boner from growing pains and your group of friends to
where like you're hanging out and you're like,
hey dude,
that thing with your goatee or like make that fart noise or like something
stupid where he had some weird human trick but then,
then you'd see him talk to women and you're like,
we should probably get out of here.
You know,
cause he's gonna like take it up a notch and fall in love and start calling
girls flour.
You know,
he doesn't have it but it's coming from us that they can't just keep fucking
harassing.
Check.
Look,
you call her wine,
she doesn't answer.
That's it.
She's not fucking interested in you bro.
Like stock got your video.
She got it.
I took in maybe like don't put the ceiling fan in it next time.
It's everything backdrop matters though,
right?
If you're going to get a home video,
a selfie video,
you'd be in the hot tub or maybe like,
I dunno,
I dunno what the move is like be beholding the parakeet or something.
You don't even know half of the show.
She eventually baited him cause she was like,
when she finally found the humor in it,
she was like,
I want to do like,
I want to get another one of these.
Cause she eventually thought it was funny.
Oh that's her and her friends were like,
send us another video.
Oh boy did
mom's house exclusive.
We thought for real and share it with you and discuss.
I haven't been this excited since.
Cool.
Runnings.
Hit DVD.
Just one is it is the exclusive.
We'll be back to talking less the wrong thing.
Here we go.
This is a [inaudible] exclusive.
All right.
That's why you guys are the best by the way.
Little things like that go a long way.
Uh,
but this is the video.
This is the last one she got from who sing.
See I'm half asleep on the couch.
There's a pointed you got me wrapped around your finger
but that's all you get.
I'm exhausted.
Too
much of a delay before a kiss is bad news.
Do kisses like that.
Why does it hurt my soul?
It hurts.
It hurts my stomach.
Just my stomach hurts and barriers.
In 10 years you'd be like,
Hey,
oh wait,
play it again.
It's so like
I feel like that's the end of his commercial when he was like,
hey it's me.
What's his name again?
Joe.
Come on down to Joe's syrup farm where you can get the best syrup in Tallahassee
and he does that.
He does that like self imposed sexy laugh.
He was like,
you know,
like it's like just hanging on the couch.
Too sexy to get up.
Yes.
Whoa.
Wrapped around my finger.
This is all you're getting.
See this one he went,
he's old.
He went full.
Tried to see.
He's less desperate.
The reason he's less desperate in this one is because she prompted him to send
something.
So all like he's so eager and the other ones,
cause he doesn't know what's going to get now he's sitting back being loud.
Who's coming to me now?
I guess I can chill on the couch to that first one.
I don't know.
I don't think I have to do any production value.
If that is the first one had to like,
I will find you.
I will follow you.
I will end things five.
And now he's like,
oh,
she's interested.
So when someone's interested,
you feel like you can do,
uh,
you know,
kind of
came around,
you know,
that's why I get a swag I like too,
is the forced spontaneity.
I'm like,
I'm just here laying on my couch
laid down before that maybe.
Do you think you practice
or like,
I should've done a long a beat between the last word have held out longer before
the smooch noise.
Tell you to smooch seals the deal.
Pause a four second.
You feel it out,
dude.
It's weird,
but be on the couch for it.
Um,
what about the floor got me wrapped around your finger with this is all you get.
I want to know what he was anticipating.
He might give her if she did ask for more though.
You know what does she texted back?
Don't let that be it.
Oh,
you want more?
Huh?
Well let's move to the bathroom change.
I bet.
What if,
what if she had baited him with like a fake God?
She was like,
let me see that.
Oh,
we don't know what this guy's capable of.
Oh yeah.
What do you think?
That's where it draws the line.
He,
yeah,
you're right.
He wouldn't be awesome.
Became a gentleman and he was like,
Julia,
I'm a classy guy.
I thought you were classy.
Not Interested.
That would be the best thing.
That's awesome.
God.
Now you want me to reopen this exchange?
The Joe.
What if Julia were to respond now and be like,
I'm ready.
It's been a few years.
All these guys were wrong.
You were always right and lucky for you.
I've still been on my couch.
He's got to know by now,
right?
That show that people are sending in their own jove videos.
Oh,
by the hundreds.
Oh boy.
Like they've just been nonstop kids.
You know,
yesterday,
Julie,
my favorites.
So many.
Not like your ex boyfriend.
I just wanted to show you the ceiling
demonstrate so we can,
when we go full throttle,
Julia,
I think.
Yes dude.
All right.
That guy went forward.
Now the best would be if you get a surprise video from Garth Brooks backstage at
his concert being like Julian back here,
getting ready to perform for you.
20,000 people screaming your name,
screaming my name,
screaming,
your name,
family if Garth.
And that's how he tells you and that's how he lets you know like nothing else.
He just sends you that dude.
Why are you tease me?
Like,
sorry dude.
Now that would be amazing.
Yeah,
that would do nothing but Garth promos for the rest.
God's got a show coming up in Florida tomorrow nights.
Seven 30
question.
Do you think that if Joe has been made aware of the relentless taunting that
we'd been giving him,
learn the error of his ways,
do you think that this experience would have changed if he's cognizant enough to
recognize the humor in what's happened
now to realize that what he did to Juliet was so fucking inappropriate and
wrong?
I think he's just like,
she wasn't for me anyway.
Some part of his mind flowers out there that's in him for sure.
There's a part of this that you should hear to answer that question because this
phrase in particular shows that in the moment when he sent the original one,
he had some awareness.
Correct.
And here is the phrase,
this is the type of guy you got.
I'm a very handy guy.
I love to build you whatever you want.
You're a sweetheart.
So I hope this video doesn't scare you.
There it is.
That's how I feel now is that it scared.
Okay.
See you or have enough awareness to go,
I hope this video didn't scare you because he knows a debt now that was it scary
or to say that,
you know what I'm saying?
Where it's like,
I don't know.
I mean whole like prefacing it with that thing that you like.
Is it scary like right?
He knows,
but he knows it's an aggressive move to send someone like a three minute video
the day after you met them in a parking lot that that what fall down did he say,
no,
I don't want this to scare you,
but I feel like we should be together all the time from here on out and you
should leave your x and I can help you kill them.
Don't be scared.
That put his head in my ceiling fan videos of scare you.
What'd he say after that?
Right after that gold Trump type of guy.
Again,
I'm a very scare you,
but that's how I feel.
I feel.
I just want you to know that I look forward.
I'm going out to dinner with,
you know,
so let's make it happen.
Oh God.
Oh,
so that's his calling card.
His mood.
It's closer.
Oh,
you still doing the kiss,
kiss,
kiss love.
They love the,
come on,
come on man.
By the way,
you think that's,
that's his first date to like,
instead of like,
he just stands five feet away from him and just goes all right.
Ucla and backs away and just like those,
the side,
not
even a real kiss.
No,
it's the first day baby.
You've got to come inside for that.
Let's see.
I was telling her,
I feel like I ever did that.
Like that it was never a thing in the forties or 50s I feel he oddly does for
his romantic interest.
Things that you would do for it.
Like a child.
Yeah.
Did you see like a kid you might go ah,
yeah cause you over exaggerating or a dog,
that kind of thing.
It's just weird that that's your,
that's your lane for where did he learn that?
What did he see that in a movie or it was like an old black and white a talky me
like,
Ma,
I love you sweetheart.
Um,
I gotta show you something.
She doesn't know this but this,
no,
this is good.
Do you remember like a week or two ago?
No,
this is a good one.
I promise.
Week or two ago.
You know,
a lot of people have picked up on that.
We having fun with Garth.
Somebody made an Instagram post.
Yeah.
That was so well done.
It's great.
People thought that it was me doing a joke,
but actually she's a video effects artist and she faced swapped me with Garth.
No Way.
And she,
so people were like,
I can't believe you got the hat and you put them like,
what are you talking about?
She put my face on a video of him.
Brilliant.
But like scary where I saw it.
I was like,
Ooh.
Like I dropped my phone and it was Jenna Sunday and uh,
she's a video effects artist in Vancouver.
So this is the video that she made.
Just like for fun.
She put this up,
okay.
The dream still lives in my dream is for us to love one another.
All of us.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
Wait a second,
man isn't ready for that.
No,
no.
Do it again.
Fucking freaked me out.
But I like it.
Yeah.
I don't like it,
but I like it.
Dreams still this and my dream is for us to love one another.
Yeah.
I mean it's
so what it would look like.
Imagine like I opened my phone like what in the fuck?
Because I thought I've seen Photoshop,
but you see a mouth moving and you're like,
no.
And it doesn't look like,
you know how uh,
like Conan used to do those things where he'd do the face and the mouth.
Now it's full on the person.
So anyways,
I reached out to her.
I told her how big of fans we were,
you know,
and I said,
well,
I was like,
I go,
this is amazing.
Can you do any others?
Let's get physical and music.
I like that
stupid.
Your eyes.
Oh,
like everything is dependent on,
she explained it to me a little bit.
Everything's dependent on body position lighting and like what,
what is available of me lines
up with completely normal cover.
So you're,
you're making an expression.
Yes.
By the way,
these have got to make his way to guards inbox and this is when he goes Torrens.
Either it's gone too far or like,
alright,
now I respect the art form now
I like that.
That's got a little Nicholson to it as well.
I want to post cool stuff,
slick stuff,
meat stuff,
but most of the stuff I'm going to post is going to be raw stuff like this.
It's so raw on the age in my element.
Is this like a,
on my Instagram,
if you follow this is when he announced that he was joining Facebook.
He made the weirdest post of all.
You don't know about that.
That's what started it.
Will Smith Join Instagram?
Like that was a big deal too,
but obviously he did it in a very cool big Willie style way.
You know?
He wasn't like,
this is going to be where you get the raw Willie's stuff.
You know?
This is nothing cool about guard social media and that's the problem.
Is there anything wrong?
He's like,
you're going to get raw stuff like me telling you about how rod's going to get,
there's no rod's going to get just me talking about the rawness that Garth is
going to deliver.
You gotta see this.
This is the actual video.
This is the real,
okay,
so this is just imagine you just joined Facebook like Facebook a year and a half
ago or something and decide to pose of this for joining Facebook.
Well,
I guess it's official.
We're now on Facebook.
I really wasn't sure about this at the start,
but then a friend of mine said something that just made all kinds of sense.
She said,
think of it more as a conversation.
I like that,
but I'm already finding out on my own,
so it's wiping the walls out between you and me and I really liked that.
It allows us into each other's worlds where I can,
I guess in my case,
hotel room.
What if he was watching tip toes?
I think I want to post,
I want to post cool stuff,
slick stuff,
neat stuff.
But most of the stuff I'm going to post is going to be raw steel.
You gotta pick one man,
cause that's a whole different genres looking raw.
This is to keep doing that sexy voice
slicks down.
Hey Man.
So this is truly a conversation.
There we go.
Did I say let the conversation begin?
If the editor with a,
then I'd be like,
all right,
I'm on board.
Slick stuff like come on back for more raw Garth.
I really like that.
This is,
is this getting as much attention from the world as you guys are giving it on
the side stuff?
Garth is a hindrance to social media.
Oh yeah,
we,
well I don't know if he's getting,
we're,
you're doing a lot of the legwork and his,
his educating America or you know,
he's the actual meet his Instagram is over.
It is over.
Is destroyed.
It's destroyed.
Yeah.
We've infiltrated
do,
there's going to be meet and greets where people are like coming up to him like,
oh you're writing for telling them some of these soundbites.
Do the meet and greets are mommies are probably gonna be like,
Hey Hitler,
where am up for stroke gang high and tight.
He's like,
why is everyone telling me they want to jerk off of me the way that something
that's been going?
Oh yeah.
They're like,
we'll come in for stroke.
All these comments are inside jokes from us and they're usually vile,
but like,
like weirdly veiled or like they don't add up.
If you don't know what it,
that's why everyone's like,
what's going on here?
This is when he,
you're going to get them.
By the way,
I just feel like Garth,
come on.
Come on man.
Come on.
I got to know about,
okay.
Weird with us.
How about this?
I challenged it to the mommies.
I know you can do this because you guys have risen to every challenge we've ever
posed.
Yeah.
If somebody here can meet Garth Brooks,
get a video of you meeting him at a meet and greet or something.
There you go.
And throw out some moms,
your moms house phrases.
That will be the ultimate.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
We've got him to do them.
Oh my God,
that's actually,
cause sometimes they're just so unaware and famous where they're like,
hey,
say happy birthday to my aunt Judy and then say,
uh,
you know,
and then he was big.
Oh Shit.
And they'll just keep your jeans high and tight.
Jeans up.
Todd and Christine then game over.
Yeah,
it is.
It is game.
But we'll move on after that.
Oh,
that would be,
but look,
I didn't want to be,
I didn't want it.
These videos to just be me.
Oh sure.
I also asked if she could do one or two of you.
Oh,
it's Tricia and my Trisha Yearwood.
You want to see her work day?
Let's see,
Jenna Sundays VFX work for Christina.
Okay,
let's see.
Wait [inaudible] Sunday
especially.
Oh,
oh my God.
That's supportive.
Thank Yo.
Gabba
hey sweetie.
That's Kim.
And I know,
I know.
I remember
in my,
I saw two gentlemen is home with extremely large,
especially
that's supportive venture.
Horrendous at another way.
If you want to see what horrible person.
Oh,
she topped it.
You want to see it?
I don't know.
Here we go.
Here you go with your hit song.
Stay United Day,
United States,
and they use day in those days a lot.
Even
my face looks a lot smoother than that.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
Can I have this to put on my social media?
Yes,
you can.
On the Christina p Instagram,
just so you know.
Oh my God.
I had a feeling that was my next guest.
If you were like,
I'm going to face you think comes with that sound.
That
would have been,
oh my God.
I wonder if you remember the golden voice guy.
I bet you don't remember that guy that got discovered on the side of the road
and he was 95.5 and then you got like a Kraft singles commercial in that Kraft
macaroni and cheese and he's like,
Yep,
rubber cheese sauce and your taint.
And they were like,
dude,
I think we got to mix it up.
You're good.
We're good on that take.
His voice was not,
he was unbelievable though.
Yeah,
but then Denise smoke a bunch of crack.
well he blew all his money.
They gave him like 40 grand.
And you can't give someone who's been living on the street.
No,
no.
Just a windfall.
You'll get it together.
Right.
All right,
so here we go.
Like it doesn't work.
Like give them like $10 a day.
Yeah,
don't spend it all in one a program.
Couple more.
You want to see a couple more?
Oh those are,
by the way,
that's my new favorite thing that I've seen on the Internet.
Cause that quality does matter.
It does because that really,
you know,
you can't terrifying.
Like with that first one especially be like at that level she threw that
together casually.
You know it didn't spend like weeks doing it.
Yeah.
Like what is capable?
What is possible with all face swapping?
Oh two where like maybe they're doing it toward them.
People post videos.
I mean with this Kevin Hart Shit that's going on.
What if somebody posted some video with his face being like,
and we got the tweets.
We also have old footage of him saying stuff,
but I mean the Jews
through juicing,
we were thought we were just talking about gays and especially the Jews.
I don't know.
Maybe make Burke Chrysler the racist.
You Ready?
Ready for this one gene?
Okay,
here we go.
Along can
take about 10,
12.
Benham girl.
Before you want to have your sexual fun with your partner.
I hate that so much.
How about this
machine?
Yeah,
machine.
She's 16.
Jeez.
16.
You guys are not on youtube yet.
Subscribing.
You have to subscribe to your mom.
How's channel?
You have to double it.
That's video.
Holy Crap.
I've got another Christina one here.
Hello?
One free buddy.
Oh boy.
That's when it's good.
It's really good.
Full God.
Why would you capture that?
Why'd you do that?
I was a good idea at the time and time.
Everyone was asking me.
Everybody wanted me to do it.
Show us what it looks like.
She did such an amazing job.
I want to point this out before I show her last one.
So Jenna is uh,
he did,
uh,
forming at Yuk Yuks for the,
this is going to be a standup for mental health 2018 summer class graduation
show.
Very cool.
Performing in this
for me in it.
Great.
That's what I'm plugging it.
Um,
so it's going to be Sunday,
January,
January 13,
20 seventeen@sevenpmatyukyuksyoucangotosmhsociety.org for tickets.
I believe all the tickets will benefit all profits.
Go to the SMH society.
It's all mental health.
Um,
so if you're in the Vancouver area,
you want to support very talented,
funny young lady and her class,
uh,
go to Smh,
society.org.
She made these,
which are just a fantastic,
it was amazing.
Super talented.
It's really good.
Right?
And that's her last one that I know resonate with everybody who watches this
show.
But I'll just have to,
that's going to take hours to do that.
That's not an easy,
just drag I thing.
So yeah,
you spend a lot of times ready,
Black Gospel.
It's a fuck you fuck
black guy.
Oh my God,
it's 23 if you want to move in,
you can move and you got to fuck man.
I have any,
I need to be fucked a lot.
Get referee for free rent and everything else,
man.
He has a deal,
He's from jail,
homeless.
Oh my God.
This is the landlord,
right?
Fuck man.
You,
you or Elise and Achilles.
I mean I'm seeing my face on it as calling in to see me when I come up with
today and try it out.
Try it out.
Does that Tribbey does it feel like an old sketch you did?
You're like,
forget like Debbie,
we can do a video back in the day that be surfaced.
I married students and stuff in college.
It was just me before stand up like my bills and tried out and I fucking pissed
on me.
I have to say,
yeah,
this is amazing.
This one is especially creepy because your face shape and your dark under eye
circles kind of mad themselves to him.
Yeah,
like yeah.
I didn't realize the similarity between you and to try it out.
Thank you very much.
There are a lot of similarities.
Similarities.
Uh,
I will post,
I mean this whole highlight,
we'll be on our youtube channel,
but I'll post a couple of those on my Instagram page.
Watch.
Holy Shit.
God.
Somebody had to ask for advice.
Maybe Adam can jump in on it.
Says Hi Tim and Christine.
I am a new college student.
I'm having a hard time adjusting to a bathroom situation.
Mainly the toilet,
the toilet paper department as a hairy boy,
I required okay man.
Plenty of wiping once he's up on the personal nickname.
I know Harry boy,
I'm a hairball being finished using the toilet and this is something I was okay
with,
uh,
until getting to college at home.
I have a nice soft toilet paper,
don't have any problems getting it all cleaned up back there.
But now there seems to be some problems.
My butthole is not only chafed active,
the amount of times I need to wipe,
but also I need to white even more with the lower quality paper.
Oh.
And like warm
like dorms or the where they really just,
they go to Kinko's and they're like,
do you guys got any leftover sheets?
What kind of deal can we get on 100,000 rolls of paper?
That's what they him,
they were like,
this shit's
fucking a dime.
We get this.
I just thought it was our dorms.
Good to know that it's universal.
That dorm 12 paper was inferior.
I'm not going to let your boat with his toilet paper.
Yeah,
so that's,
so he used the word,
so he says,
how do you believe I should bring about a change?
I don't want college tuition rates to go up because of the change and toilet
paper quality,
but I can't keep living this way.
No.
Also another thought,
maybe it communal,
but day could be an order.
There's a lot to ask from your soul is,
so he's in college,
he's in college.
I mean,
you know,
but the day,
I mean,
come on.
Nobody offers that happen.
You can do that.
I mean,
here's the thing though.
These,
these kids,
man,
they get together and are changing the world.
You get a Facebook,
getting them marching on campus,
like clean our ad is good.
Like,
you know,
like all the Harry boys got together and together we'll stay together.
You Go,
yeah,
yeah.
And you've got to find a bunch of Harry voice.
Bunch of bunch of Harry Boyd Crusading for Harry boy writes.
There you go.
But boy is spelled boy Harry [inaudible] Harry styles to help lead the charge
the most.
Like I'm the hairiest of the Harry Boys.
The more he could fucking exaggerate how marginalized your group.
That's right.
More hysteria you can create.
I mean,
the president of your school will soon be like,
ah,
we,
I realized how wrong we've been for so long.
Ignoring the Harry Boys.
You stir the pot enough.
Yeah.
Someone's going to have to take a sip.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Fucking cool.
Said that
the only other options are shaved your ass.
Wax Your ass.
A flushable toilet wipes.
But maybe that's expensive for a college.
A lot.
You can afford those.
Yeah.
So or maybe he can,
maybe he's one of those rich college kids.
It's like,
no,
he's not gonna.
He's not going to get a fucking today.
It's not going to happen.
He's got a hairy asshole.
Right.
You have to invest in wipes.
At this point,
there are more discreet to carry into the bathroom than a role of your own
toilet paper,
which is another suggestion I would say by a high quality and just PR girl to
see you.
Why the Weird Guy Walking into the bathroom?
TP It's gross.
It's weird.
She's like,
oh,
is it Byo tp?
And he goes,
Eh,
oh I guess it is.
It's like I don't want you to be scared or you can chip in with some guidelines
on your floor and you guys can chime in together.
Get to make it a dude's thing.
They got a dude's nine out of school,
get the better tp tonight.
And you guys just have like a stack of roles and the toilet and then you,
you share it.
But then,
yeah.
And then that's gonna you know,
maybe there's like a 10 bucks a month type thing.
Yeah.
But that is an issue though.
College does.
That's the one thing that um,
I think they do slack on,
you know,
I mean you pay so much money.
I'm trying to go back to like,
you know,
my wiping days in college and it's,
Oh,
I'm having a tough time remembering fully,
but I know it wasn't like great and over.
No,
no,
it never was walking out being like what was the best part about college?
Oh Man.
The acting school was pretty cool,
but I got the cleanest fucking bottle,
you know,
like I have another suggestion for him actually.
I don't know where your showers are in proximity to your toilet.
That's a great question.
I used to earn our dorms.
The showers were right there so you could shit and then go straight to shower.
It's a little gross in a communal.
I know,
but what are your options?
You know,
you got to keep your be hopefully if you want to get laid,
and I know that's a priority for college guys out there and girls,
you really get laid.
You really do.
It's a time about this question.
It says,
good morning Julia,
in order in an older episode,
Tom Trick Christina into getting on all fours so that he could milk her.
Tom then requested that listeners try it out.
Report back about the reaction.
See years ago,
that was years ago,
yesterday I got my wife down in her hands and knees as had reached for her Tichy
yield.
Are you going to fucking milk me?
That's the last straw today she served as a board divorce papers and I honestly
cannot.
I have to go to work now.
Mwah.
Ciao baby.
Love Joe.
Point guys,
the Milkman.
I remember that.
I remember that
shit like you would get on your four is I want to show you something and then
you started.
He started to milk my tits and I was like,
Hey God.
Was it like a weird fetish or what kind of drive me finding,
yeah,
it'd be a clown.
I shirtless at the time,
my rabbits,
my mom.
Uh,
how about this one gene for you?
It says,
Hey,
Hitler's my triple d slut.
Wife always has positive
comments.
Email opening one up guys.
So anyway,
my big ass teddy was
very familiar.
It's still amazing.
They want to know about your lipstick twice.
If she wants to know what branch is pacifically the red ones so that she can try
it out.
Bradley.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you guys once and for all,
because I get many inquiries.
I lot of you've been asking about the scarf I'm wearing.
A lot of people are asking.
Yes.
Wait,
Tom and I'm,
do you ever have people on ever seen him on Instagram?
They were like,
a lot of people have been asking about this shirt I wear.
It's like,
can you take your,
like people keep hitting me up about this hat.
You're like,
what to fucking nobody asked her.
Like I can barely fucking walk through the airport.
Okay.
Nobody fucking ass views.
Okay,
so I'll tell you finally once and for all.
Molly's going to say at once,
God,
you're girl uses,
I'll tell you there's a few different shades,
but the bat,
the brand is called Smashbox and it's made specifically for like television or
long way.
That's why I wear it.
It lasts forever on stage.
The color I generally wear.
It's called infra red,
but not breaking something.
I'm sorry.
It's called infra I.
N f R.
A,
R e,
d.
And it'll stay on for fucking hours and hours,
but infrared yet it's a matte Smashbox.
There you go.
This,
uh,
this,
this email was making me laugh.
So another email came in.
It says,
my question is for the water champ herself.
Miss Christina.
Thank you.
I'm finally getting a lot of acknowledgement as a fellow lady of Hungarian
descent or proud bow hunt,
if you will.
I have found that I am an avid consumer of water.
In fact,
I would say that my bow hunt mother and I drink more water than anyone else.
I know my boyfriend never drinks water and I often find myself disgusted by the
color and smell of his urine.
They can't understand how anyone can drink anything other than water when they
are truly parched.
How do you deal with the fact that Tommy only consumes his Kako water?
Start with because of that.
How do you smell?
How do you handle the smell of his man?
Juices piss on me and beat me.
And keep them high and tight.
Love Ashley all,
yeah,
go ahead.
I'll tell you real talk that this,
the whole discussion about the water champ came because Tom peed in the shower
with me.
Oh boy.
And it smelled like someone had dumped a crap of coffee in the Goddamn.
Did you give a heads up or do you start going,
oh,
he just went into Tesco.
His wife to your lady.
No,
that's,
is that a,
do you wait till marriage for that or no?
No,
no.
He did get out of the way before.
So you know,
like if you're cool.
Yeah.
If you're a real cool then you'll be all right with this.
That's how I broke the fart barrier in the most bold of ways.
We have been dating a little bit and the Harrison Ford in the fart barrier
spit.
Uh,
that was so rad.
I was a jack.
Ryan smells like shit.
I was like,
Shit.
How did it get in here?
The Fort Barry Harris,
sorry.
A lot of great movies.
People sleep on the far barrier.
Air Force One,
all the Indiana Jones,
the far barrier where it's like there's a running from the terrorism terrorist
group and they take over the US Capitol and they have a fart Barry outside and
nobody wants to go in and just save them.
You don't remember that movie movie's wounds farting on the outside of it and
the most respectable act,
he never is frivolous ever.
Even at the Laker game last night and they put him on the jumbo tron,
Harrison Ford and the fucking thing Kevin Costner was,
wow.
That was me.
He's already entered into my mind guys.
Yeah,
no,
there was Lucy Lu,
Jesus.
I have two small children.
I have no bandwidth.
They have will Ferrell was there.
He got huge one.
Denzel was there.
That's a big one.
That should always be the biggest.
It was actually,
it was the biggest except that,
um,
it was the biggest for acknowledgement.
Yeah,
but we'll perform to meaning.
So we'll got even bigger as a comedian did something funny.
What happened was like Kevin Concert didn't even know he was on,
like his kid kept being like,
you're on the fucking dance.
Come on man.
Right.
So he was like that and before that was,
oh,
Jessica Biel got a big ovation.
Very cool.
Uh,
what's the quarterback do your golf for the rams.
He got meat.
I don't think they even knew it was,
I don't think they recognize him honestly.
He looks like a contestant on double dare or wild and crazy kids grew up and
so it's like building build is like,
oh,
people are cheering,
cheering.
Then Denzel,
they go fucking ape shit.
Love it.
But then they cut to will Ferrell after him.
Big Ovation and he goes,
and will's angry.
Funny.
Yes.
The best last leg room I went to met Jack Nicholson,
one of my favorite actors of all time.
He's at the game.
He leaves at one point.
And um,
and uh,
we were,
we were sitting,
we had access to this,
like there's like a side room that's like,
we can get drinks and food.
Like at half time of war,
we weren't on the floor,
but we were in,
we just had access to it somehow.
Okay.
Um,
my buddy add them to mine so he's got tickets to see such a big clippers game
fan.
He will big NBA Fan and I think Omaha we grew up,
didn't have a team.
I think when he got out here he was just like I'm a clippers.
Yeah,
Lakers were.
I can't,
I don't know how he got to Griffin and Chris Paul and deandre Jordan and they
were 14 and they were workaholics fans.
So it was like a mutual thing.
I think they might've hit him up and then he went to games and,
because I remember him being a clippers fan for a lie since he got here.
Okay.
Yeah.
But I mean when he got,
he woulda got here when the Lakers were smashing.
Yep.
I'm taking the other side,
the other side.
Um,
so we,
we go back.
All those guys are,
sorry,
all the clip of the,
I remember all the workaholics guys would go to those games.
Right.
Erik Griffin goes,
they got season tickets so they would go,
Eric is the most insane person to go to a basketball game with cause he just
talks so much shit.
I mean in the best and the best way.
And you just got that big voice roof boy and he's like,
wait all walk,
oh shade.
And they fucking turn around all the time and someone's,
they recognize them so then they laugh and other times they're just like,
man,
fuck you.
You know.
But so we go to the back area and there's this little like bar area and then you
go to the bathroom and you walk straight back and then there's like a two doors
to the bathroom and then like a little hallway in the back where you can kind of
almost wait or there's a chair in the back corner facing where your people are
standing in line to get into the bathrooms.
And I just walked back there and Jack's just sitting back there,
legs spread,
holding the coffee,
looks like just an old man chilling on a porch like just back.
They're just like,
ah,
sunglasses on,
smiling,
not talking to anybody.
So now there's all these dudes and girls lined up.
I mean,
it's smaller,
maybe four or five.
And everyone sees him and he's looking at us kind of looking down and you're
trying to like,
everyone's gauging like,
do I say something?
So one dude in front of,
and he's like looking at the girls as they go into the bathroom and you know,
have a good one.
He muttered something.
Yeah,
good.
Yeah.
Good luck with that.
Pissed,
you know?
And uh,
and uh,
and so that pice,
I mean,
again,
paraphrasing,
but he said some and they curse laughed like how many,
you know,
Jack Nicholson?
And then I remember the guy in front of me was like,
I got toilet paper.
He was like,
I'm going to throw a hail Mary and say SOM.
So he goes,
what's up Jack?
And he goes,
hey.
[inaudible] you doing man?
And he goes,
takes a pause,
looks down,
and then goes,
the fuck does it look like I'm doing?
Yeah.
And he goes,
I'm drinking a coffee in the corner and I go,
awesome.
And then the guy goes,
hell yeah man.
And he goes
like,
fucking guy.
And then he goes through and then I get up there and I'm like,
hey man,
I'm an actor,
you're the man.
And like,
you know,
and then he was like,
cool.
I go,
yeah man,
I got an act and you were my favorite.
Still are like,
you're God,
hope you're having a good time.
He goes,
it's a great time to live,
isn't it?
And I was like,
yeah man,
what are we gonna see in movies again?
He was like,
who knows?
And I was like,
yeah,
fair enough.
You know?
Yeah.
You did a real fan thing though.
That was cool.
January and polite.
Yes.
And also it's like a guy like,
you know,
we're talking about like to approach like I don't know what to say.
Oh Man.
There's also in such a confined area that I was like,
sometimes you know,
it's weirder to just stand there in silence.
Yeah.
I mean,
not for like urinal small talk.
I'm a big non advocate of that.
Like if someone talks to you.
I remember one time some guys said something,
he was like,
man,
I don't these urinals like two,
uh,
two small and mixed.
My,
uh,
are too big.
It makes me feel like my Dick's do small.
And like basically it would have been weird if we not to say anything.
So I was like,
yeah man,
you know,
I bet you're fine.
You know,
like just chime in,
back end.
It's like,
no,
look,
look at it.
You think it's like don't talk at the urinal.
She asked how I deal with it.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So the point is is that you sometimes drink so little water and I'm being
serious.
If you look at our desk right now,
what's he drinking?
Brown soda.
It's not bright.
And sometimes when you drink a lot of coffee ground during the day,
I can smell it coming out of your pores.
I'll smell your forehead and it'll smell like calm going to get one after this.
But you get that mocha forehead,
by the way,
that's the name of the,
um,
the lead actor.
The young kid in fart barrier is mocha forehead.
Forehead.
Yeah.
He's trying to break out
cause there's always like an a move back that there's always some young kid that
you're like,
who's this guy?
What's his real name?
No,
that's it.
Apparently he's been acting since he was a fucking toddler.
I'll show you his cheerios commercial,
but you don't pee enough because you don't hydrate enough.
I'm the same way,
man.
I need more.
What are you just so much coffee drinking black fluid too.
He's drinking lack fluid.
You're drinking oil.
You're gonna,
you're gonna get kidney stones.
If this,
right now I'm trying to think of is that's going to be a painful thing.
I'm trying to think of what I would say to Jack Nicholson too though.
I feel like I know what I'd ask him what we were talking about last night.
When you're sitting in my house last night,
Dawg,
you smile because he sits court side now.
How does Jack Nicholson take a piss during the Laker game?
He'd just get swarmed by fans.
What do you think passed when he's sitting fucking court side with a little
bottle?
Just whips it out.
That's what I was saying.
One side you get like,
it's like the benefit of being that close.
They're like,
ah,
we love,
it's a lot of publicity for us if you want to put out and just go.
And he was like,
I was already planning on,
I'm planning on it and then one of the Laker girls comes over with a cup holds
it,
pulls his dick out.
Yeah this is into it here,
but I'll shake myself.
Oh No,
I like it cause that's the part where he goes,
don't get weird if she does it.
I think when it gets full and like he puts his dick away,
she looks at him and he goes,
you can take a sip.
And she's like,
no.
She goes,
it tastes good.
Yeah.
You know it does.
And then get out of here.
Anger Management on TBS.
I feel like his stories of how he closed deals with checks has got to be the
greatest one.
Rival old girls.
Do you think he's nailed?
Because,
great question.
Obviously that's happened.
I mean there's so many different genres of women that you could ask that
question about what we could be like,
how many women do you think he's nailed?
How many,
how many women at Laco fucking places.
I'm saying,
cause he's at the games every week.
We're talking to eighties nineties two thousands right?
Seventies right.
They make what,
$50 not a lot.
One of my buddies girls was for awhile and it sucked me into it just to give you
two seats and they were up in the nosebleeds and they're just like,
this is a privilege.
If you don't want to do it,
we'll find somebody and they will.
They will talk.
What was that story about the cowboys cheerleaders?
Something like,
but back to your thing,
Nicholson has smashed a lot,
probably more than wilt Chamberlain or they said,
you know,
it was all like,
let's say like over like a million.
He said he served like 53 a day for filming.
Yeah.
Jack Nicholson did not get famous until he was about 28 or 30 years old.
I would say older than that.
Okay,
so let's say what?
Mid Thirties yeah,
maybe late.
So easy rider.
He does when he's 28 that's the big one.
Now you look at somebody like Justin Bieber who's been busting nuts since he was
like,
that's true.
That's a really good point.
Since he wrote Bustin nuts.
Yeah.
Bieber has been started.
He started earlier.
So you've,
you know what I'm saying?
You have to take that into account when you're looking at nuts busted throughout
the years.
So when is Nicholson,
when does he get famous?
Can we look that up?
Yeah,
let's do the math.
Let's see.
It was cuckoo's nest.
Was that you're no,
I'm sorry.
Shining.
Shining,
shining.
Oh
yeah,
hold on to,
let's see.
Jack Nicholson,
who was that guy in acting class?
81 now he's 81 yeah,
I started late.
I saw 81 year old Jack Nicholson.
Yeah.
Tell someone like,
what the fuck do you,
does it look like I'm doing this?
He doesn't have as much old man swagger to
Tom.
Right.
If he's starting fucking at like 30 so he made like,
you know what I'm saying?
If I Agra didn't come around until when early two thousands do you think this
guy fucked a lot though?
Give me a break.
You're like,
hey you,
you'd say like Jack,
do you sleep well?
He's like,
well I don't have any come lifted.
He's all brittle.
If he said that on like a Jay Leno interview,
if there's a soundbite of him somewhere,
I'd be like,
how do you sleep Jag?
Well there's no come left critical writer.
So that's his last,
let's see if we could pull my God,
listen,
listen.
Dot.
Yeah,
that'd be the story of I want to take for how to genuinely chronicle like just
the,
the tails.
I mean would any,
cause no one,
no Hollywood elite has ever done that,
right?
Like Lee,
these guys that are known for being just such,
yeah.
Like to actually write some book where he was like chapter one Denise chapter
840 million do math.
Are you good at math?
I'm all right.
All right,
so let's,
let's figure out this age thing cause I'm,
I'm kind of curious now.
So math,
you do the math.
So he's born in 37 okay.
I'm looking at when the calculator,
I know,
well,
I'm just trying to look at how old he was in certain things here.
So what's,
what's,
what's the big one you said?
Easy rider,
like the breakout.
So that's 69 the big one.
So that's 32 yeah.
So he's 32 he's 32 for easy rider.
And that's like the beginning of the ascent cause he's in all this stuff before
that,
that that doesn't really,
yeah.
Then Chinatown is huge.
That comes out in [inaudible] 74 that was almost like his,
hey,
here's Jack.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So that fat would be like when you really start smashing hearts.
Yeah.
So 74 he's all,
he's uh,
he's Gunna be,
what?
35 37 so he's going to be 40.
He'll,
he's 30 I'm 37 he's 37 he's 37 yeah.
37 then.
Sorry.
Yeah,
but,
but also Agra back then now.
Yeah.
But you're 37,
he's now,
he's,
he's more mature,
so he really knows how to play the game or see if you learn,
if you're chasing getting posts in your teens and early twenties,
your games kind of weak because you didn't really develop like trail actually is
way more confident and grounded because he's almost 40.
Then he wins an Oscar
for maybe,
I don't know if he wanted one for that,
but he won one for one,
flew over the Cuckoo's nest and 75.
So he's what,
uh,
about to turn 38 there.
You're getting that high end model stuff,
you know what I'm saying?
Or getting like the famous actresses are getting the Mariel Hemingway fucking
pump and dump the extras.
I think about,
I think about the girls that were like,
I'm not really a Greg Kinnear girl.
I'm more of a,
you know,
something's got to give.
You've got to have daddy issues if you're begging Nicholson.
Yeah.
He's always been old.
So,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he's always had a very,
um,
you know,
just fatherly demeanor.
It was watching Christmas vacation and Doris,
what's her name?
The mom,
the shining in 1980 are always old.
Like Alan Alan Arkin.
He's always been old.
We are linked to this park.
Is there a young Alan Arkin picture?
Probably.
I'm going to see it or look it up.
I love to see your face on an Alanon video boy.
I mean,
how old?
Yeah,
he looks old as shit and he's always just been always been old.
I have never seen him young and a film.
Same.
A Doris Leech.
There's Alan.
He's cute.
Oldest.
Fuck Damn.
Just always all so funny.
So fucking Tribeca is another one of those guys,
but I feel like has just always looked the same.
Yup.
Yup,
Let's see.
Oh yeah.
This guy right here.
Outcome.
Whoa.
No,
come left.
Totally drained.
You've got his eyebrows.
You've got Nichols.
Oh,
this guy.
Come on,
look at that smile.
Great.
Sprayed skin rocks and Hank.
Smash,
smash,
smash.
Smash.
Oh yeah,
come on.
Come on.
That's the stuff.
That's the prefix is pre.
Yeah.
This is when he was like,
who am I?
Yes.
Okay,
well let's talk about drinking a coffee.
You fuck.
Let's talk about 81 years old.
It was still that guy.
I bet he's been jack all the time.
You know people that know him since he was that young,
we're like,
oh yeah,
he's always just been course.
What about Burt Reynolds?
Talk about a smash machine.
Wow.
Real Hound.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean he calendar full all the time.
Especially especially he had a more of a window,
I feel like that's what I'm feeling.
Like Nicholson's post is kind of spread out.
But Reynolds had a 10 year window where he was the king,
the king of Showbiz.
That guy was banging it.
And what about a guy like Leonardo Dicaprio?
Whole legendary,
legendary guys been smashing since and he started to know what it's like to not
be adored.
He doesn't have memories of that too.
Exactly.
So he was famous like at 14 doing movies.
Yeah.
So imagining pain's a pussy.
He was probably just right.
Was that cute little kid onset?
All he's done for Cameron's like,
dude,
why he's fucking land.
Save yourself.
He's got to be like early forties right?
Right.
Yeah.
Early forties,
and he's just been a movie star for decades about Kirk Cameron.
When he was on growing pains,
was he,
was he Christian then?
Yeah.
He wasn't smashing.
No.
He was being like a good pen.
Yep.
What a waste.
And it's with,
I know that,
but when he really came out and was just like,
God,
my kids were gay,
I'd fucking send them to uh,
you know,
gay camp,
a camp or something.
And it was just like,
oh,
you psycho.
And then he just,
and then they would go back and be like,
in a pair of the Kirk Cameron always this way.
Wow.
Just same guy did the vo for tiptoes and like the gays.
Yeah.
And he was like,
until they'd be like,
and the,
I think,
I don't know if they interviewed other actors or something.
They were like,
yeah,
man,
he was like the hottest shit ever.
But he just like the girls would come to his dressing room,
whatever,
and he'd just be like ghetto.
Like he was just very much like maybe he's on,
that's not what this is for.
And just,
you know,
he's,
he might be at him and Leo must have butted heads for sure.
Wait.
Oh,
must've been gay inside.
Sure.
You know what I mean?
When you fight it that hard.
I mean,
that's so nice.
You think so when you're like,
I hate the get.
Yeah.
I would send my kid to gay,
can barely,
you know that he knows something else is going on.
And he goes,
yeah,
exactly.
Look at a guy.
All this blood goes down.
So it's like,
Leo,
get Outta here man.
Stop telling me about all these women.
I'm going to fuck you.
No,
I'm just,
I mean,
just let's run lines.
Um,
we have to ask you a question.
Yeah.
Okay.
We've seen a,
seems to think that I find certain things funny that she doesn't find fun.
I got to go pee.
Now's a great,
oh no,
no,
no.
You gotta be here for this.
Yeah.
So the segments called horrible are hilarious.
You just watch it and you just react.
Great.
We just see what happens.
I love that guy.
I love this is this funny
fucking fuck.
Ah,
we come at you like that.
Okay.
Horrible.
Hilarious.
It's a great intro.
An intro.
Yeah.
So here's the clip you've got to watch too.
I know.
I don't want to,
but I wouldn't.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Oh,
it's going to be a oh shit.
Okay.
Yes.
Yup.
This is the difference between guys and girls when they say there's no
difference in the genders.
This is definitely man,
come on.
There's a lot of genders.
Which genders are you talking about?
A buck naked window.
Fault.
Come on,
but he's dead.
No,
he's,
hello?
Yeah.
No,
the way he hit look,
he's probably gonna get some sort of reconstructive surgery,
but yeah,
he's brought that garbage can.
Yeah,
he's bruised.
That's the thing about dudes.
There's resilient.
Like he's probably fallen out of a,
of a tree as a kid like that.
Pictures my son,
like your son is not doing this,
but he might one day.
What was that guy escaping from Hawaii?
I don't know.
But something in the day with a lot of clothes.
Yeah.
Cause he was a,
he was really trying to get out of there.
And you imagine me in that situation where like if the guy,
like I,
I immediately pictured like he was with some girl and the guy came back and he's
like,
I just got to get out now and you don't even have time to think.
And there's only one way out.
That's the guys there.
That's what you said.
Exactly what happened.
So he got outside and the guy was like,
you really going to jump out a window,
you know,
I'm just,
I don't know.
It seemed like it was a card.
It seemed like it wasn't in the back of that,
but it didn't seem local.
They didn't recognize it and recognize the font of the trash.
That's true.
What did you think was happening?
That's the only storyline.
Oh,
I thought it was a Mike.
My immediate thought was this is a mentally ill man hanging out outside
of his window.
He's having an affair and the,
and the other guy,
I'm telling you what I thought we'd have to find out more information.
Do you think he was like,
I'm going to go change the thermostat and the next thing you know he's outside
of his roommates are like,
he does this a lot.
He's a little off.
Yeah.
It's attached to that is do we see some,
but here's the thing though,
is somebody in the,
in the building the room that he was in?
Yeah.
No.
See what I mean?
Like they would have been there like pointing,
grabbing.
It's like he's alone.
Well,
maybe the wife is dealing with her husband right now.
Does your sleep walk?
A husband probably wants to murder this guy.
He's not really trying to pull him to,
did he let go?
No.
Oh,
he's probably stuck.
God,
I love the one person there that just had no clue.
So one was hanging.
I know,
right?
Yeah,
you're right.
If she turned over here,
fuck over here.
Someone dammit.
Darin.
This buildings full of naked dudes hanging outside the,
well,
yeah.
This person doesn't real.
You're right.
Yeah.
Say she turns around a long leash.
Imagine just walking
that,
the shop carrying your laundry.
How about Mr?
I don't even flinch.
This guy was just like,
he was waiting for it.
Maybe that's the guy.
Maybe that's the guy that was in the room.
Now I can think he's outside the window and he goes,
he goes,
go ahead.
Hang out there.
I'll meet you downstairs.
Yeah.
Yeah,
cause he doesn't even flinch.
Doesn't even flinch.
He bounced off at trash cans.
So nut.
That's a lucky fall too.
Cause he is fine.
Yeah.
He's all right.
If you miss those trash cans,
that's it.
That's a wrap on the day.
So what's the vote?
Horrible are hilarious.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Christina,
you guys are sociopaths,
both of you and you have no,
no,
no.
I think that's the hard,
that's what you mean to say?
No,
no,
it's holidays.
I find that rude of you to say.
How do you find physical stuff like that?
Funny at all is because he wasn't clothed.
No.
I as a mother and you don't think of your son's doing crazy shit as a person of
earth,
a sweet person,
a person,
a person with sympathy and I can put myself in other people's shoes.
You are good at that.
I just don't,
I don't like.
Okay.
Hilarious.
My veneer fucking fake teeth.
What about like jackass stuff?
Don't find anything.
I loves it,
but you know,
I love it.
Sociopath.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Because it's one of us.
No,
because it's not accidental.
Those are adults.
They're consenting and they're doing it of their own freewill.
That looks like an accident when they're accidental.
It's like,
oof.
They didn't want to do,
some of his buddy had looked in the camera right before and be like,
all right,
it's not for naked German wall jumps.
Yes.
And then I'd be like,
fuck yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Totally different stories.
Fair enough.
About last night is the podcast that Adam and Brad do together yet.
They're doing it for a men's drove for about five years.
Uh,
I've had Tommy on,
uh,
Sandra Bullock,
Bill Byrd,
Dana Carvey,
Mr. McCarthy,
Jason Derulo as Louise Patrick Harris.
It's a lot of fun times.
Yeah.
We got to have you on.
Brad told me when he was here,
did he tell you I listened to that and he's like,
you gotta do it sometime.
And I was like,
I heard done it,
dude,
when I listened to him say at the end,
and I go,
you're closing the podcast with,
I don't remember you were on my podcast.
I scolded him.
He beat the shit out of him.
I just kind of like put my hand down
in palm tip toe yet.
Uh,
yeah,
we do it for about five years.
It's a long time.
Yeah,
it's a blast.
And I was just telling you were,
um,
oh wait,
no,
I can't say it yet.
Oh,
you can't what I was going to say about the,
and don't forget,
you got to show me and we're going to wrap porn video.
Yeah.
And Adam,
Rick,
comedy.com for tour dates.
Um,
when's this coming out?
This will come out tonight.
Fuck yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
Tempe Improv next weekend and Arizona.
And then,
um,
January is a helium in Portland and Philly.
He read them.
It's a hard,
sorry.
Here in Portland,
in Philly.
And then Spokane comedy club.
Uh,
and then punchline in San Fran because they're all good.
They're all good.
And then a comedy works in Denver for the first time.
Oh,
I've only done the south on a pumps.
get ready to ever go back to any other club.
I know.
We just did a live podcast.
They are bright and with John Heffron and Josh blue and it was like that.
Places on fucking real magic.
I don't know.
It's something about the,
first of all just underground comedy clubs I feel like are just a little extra
special.
Right.
And then the way it,
it just holds in the,
um,
it's where I think actually I'm going to premiere the trailer for a for fart
barrier be great.
Yeah.
That was at the screening.
You're going to be making a New York or no,
so I have a couple of scenes in this Jennifer Lopez movie called Second Act if
it's coming out.
I seen the billboards,
couple scenes in,
it might be,
I've been told a couple scenes.
It could be a couple lines,
but uh,
yeah,
it's always fun.
But the director of it,
I have known for a little bit,
it seems Peter Seagal.
Uh,
he was direct to Tommy boy and like 51st dates and nutty professor and,
and um,
sweet.
Threw me the sole thing and,
and uh,
and I just want to go and hang on.
I got a buddy that's going to go with me to the premiere and it's awesome.
Yeah.
Steven Seagal makes movies too.
Yeah,
his moves are really good out.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's actually why I'm here.
Oh really?
Yeah.
We have a direct line.
I know he's,
yeah.
So bridge the gap because we're done here.
We can get your audition together.
Oh,
I already have a self tape ready to go.
Like in a file.
You look up a zip drive.
Um,
it's me doing all the lines of Gary Oldman from tiptoes.
Adam rate hilarious comedian.
Ghosty I'm live,
listened to his podcast.
Thanks for coming out.
This is a blast you guys are at,
I mean,
you knew Greg,
thanks for having me.
This a closing song is called a very handy guy by Galloway.
I Dunno.
That sounds,
that's what it is.
They send in the songs and we just play him.
Thanks a lot for listening.
We'll see you guys next.
[inaudible]
we
sure.
Well,
this whole feature wall.